that was funny huh
how goes it we're still here about Windows
Powershell
and we're back I should be back now just in
time to hear me
so yeah I could have three that I just go
and look for some questions see if we have
anything new
something I do during a May time
he wasn't posting resources
I went ahead and I made this topics instead
of old people still like their topics
I'm going to keep chat the main chat come
get you to do that
personification
anytime I go on stage is since a
notification apologize for that
so I'm just going to go through and catch up
on the resources I don't have it ready yet
yep question sounds of time we'll be done
with this in 90 minutes I'll be back to
codeine whatever I want had a great with
your game on a good went yesterday to a lot
of fun
I'm going to be doing more of that today
it's snowing outside today right now in
North Carolina that's unusual having a
pretty deep deep deep snow storm coming on
Azan it listens I guess in ozello casting
the cast and stuff
by the way back I guess you moved it I just
had installed Lennox and discovered him he
was eating something eakes
create those folders that may work for me
that strange
opposite characters right now I watched all
the sudden find it thanks anyway
for the actual tool is commands at
a curate what he created into a tool I get
to read the code so much how much people
like my Zetas guess it's gets you know what
it's not documented needs to be Rewritten
and go but it's fine
so yeah that's been fun thanks everybody
I need to document that is a command
eventually it will be coded and go and work
any OS but he's already poured it to go by
the way
you like the stage
I can send in chat only and hear audio in
real time and no need for a low player
exhausting my internet oh nice
yeah very nice
I'm glad that works out for people I did
read your chat was that you
yeah so if you're going to use the telecast
in and go ahead and do that I'm a little
ashamed of my zit because
it doesn't have any income Dominican
documentation I was very selfish I just
wrote it because I want to see Ian The Firm
fan that you should write your own Knowledge
Management I think that's one of the
greatest project you should work to do for
yourself because then you have full and
absolute control of your own Knowledge
Management and you can you know you can do
variations on with with somebody else does
Nick if there's one tool that you might want
to learn to write yourself it would be bad
if you want to lean on somebody else's so
that's fine too but that's it
that's a side encourage you to start with it
and then you'll Fork your own and then see
what you might want to change about it so
she eventually learn to understand Excedrin
is it possible to be on Windows and still be
productive or are you always going to
recommend transition to Linux have to become
more serious I don't
you know it's funny you say that five shot
because I have
toyed with going to Windows a lot and
ultimately I always realize I was out of my
mind
yeah the grass is always greener on the
other side right I
I'm always doing that I'm always doing that
I'm always going back and forth
and that's not something I want to do oh
cool
that's why I called Riani so
the answer is yes I think you should have
been totally go to Lenox it's your main
Workstation
after spending you know years on Lenox and
streaming fully from Lenox and playing all
the games they care about from Lennox I see
no reason to use Windows at all
I playing OverWatch switch I can still do
online so just have to figure out how I know
people do it though is not a reason enough I
don't not even that big of an OverWatch fan
so I have no reason not to use Linux
everyday all day
I have lots of reasons not to use
I have lots of reasons not to use other
things
and so that's I guess that's my answer
but I hope it's okay so I would eventually
move to it again for work I can't do that
right for work I can't use that making
issues windows and putty which is horrible
the back so horrible I asked him to get me a
Mac instead because at least enough to use
putty
as a lot of things yeah look if you're a big
gamer I would not use Lennox
I would not use Linux for gaming.
I wouldn't I use it for my games because it
works I'm not a big gamer I'm a real casual
so so my suggestion is to get yourself a
kick-ass MSI Trident which is about you know
$1,000 that will run every game you have at
Max settings and fit in your backpack
and work with the best highest performing
game if they called the console killer it's
called MSI Trident Linus Linus Tech tips
actually reviewed it and I didn't know that
but they did and I agree with everything
they said it's it's get a get get a gaming
PC and then get a laptop or another system
and its it doesn't need to be very high
power and use that for Lennox and it have
two computers that's my strongest
recommendation to everybody if you are going
to move into this and you're taking it
seriously have a single system for gaming
I can always buddy at work I've got used to
it but man I I'd rather have an Xbox yeah so
what everybody else I won't work for a
company that forces me to use Penny I am
done
I have done I'll make double the money
working for somebody else rather than use
Petty I won't do it it's totally stupid it's
completely unnecessary and in modern world
with of your cell and with with mac and with
you know that you can use you can use a
desktop container and contained there's no
reason to use putty today absolutely zero
but Company still say that that's the way to
do it that's how we still trading for
newbies there's just so many things wrong
with putty speak starting with colors it. It
must have put he doesn't have color support
which is really bad
cheap easy solution or do Buddhism way to go
I agree I think dual booting is a mistake
because it's going to hurt something is
unfair to Lenox cuz small-market games at to
cheat yeah if you like things like Roblox or
example of people still like it you can't do
that at all in Lenox the band you the call
you a hacker
visualize Windows Unlimited in kPa and give
him a key me to read anything on Windows
anything on Windows yeah and you can do that
I've actually been getting into keeping
lately and it will it will totally run
Windows there's you can run Windows on Linux
if you want to do it depends on most people
who want to keep windows are Gamers then I
keep it because I want to use open off and
then when you know Microsoft Office or some
shit which by the way is all in the cloud in
online now anyway so you need it yeah
there's no compelling reason
except for I performance gaming in my
opinion to keep a Windows machine around
that in SolidWorks if you're doing any kind
of like real serious engineering and you're
using tools that are only made for Windows
such as SolidWorks then yeah you're stuck
you need to have Windows or if your company
is stupid and they force you to have Windows
or Mac you don't have a choice right you do
have a choice go to another company that
understands what the fuck's up and you know
I love the company that I work for now but
I'm and they've been really really, dating
for all this stuff but but I really hated to
having to defend my position about using a
Linux workstation by saying you don't need
that you can do windows that's what all of
the people here use I might know they don't
so so they don't actually mostly machine
learning team uses Max because Windows
doesn't work
is the city is pretty good I d e d haddis
it's okay but your Visual Studio Visual
Studio Pro Studio code if you're ready to
see KO 2 C plus plus in your doing a lot of
that you probably won't windows for that but
I don't I don't do that so that job thing an
open source software as a solution for the
business problem
12 gal I mean let's look in the news lately
open-source is now considered a threat to
National Security in America we should
always was and always was
so
play switch to Lenox two years ago and I
don't mess with us for nothing not even gave
me and tastic and there's a lot of people
that would agree with that and and if you do
want to watch The One X gaming guys were
they called like what's their name Lennox
gaming guys I give him a shout out during
the video because they help me quickly with
fighting for me I'm just confirming that the
closed captioning actually does work that's
how the right thing they will prove it to
you if they do it all the time they're kind
of hard to watch cuz they're kind of
assholes actually none of that kind of
assholes they're very typical Lennox you
know assholes
of which I am one
open source is right there it's right a
threat in real or not open source is
definitely a threat
yeah there's no doubt open source has the
threat I have always thought that
open source is a threat to security because
nobody vets it
solarwinds is it good example of that
Baker Js log4j
all of them all of the biggest hacks that we
know of
all of the biggest tax that we know of have
happened because hackers could read The
Source or they had access to the store
lodash that was the other than gambling
so
I hate to say this but those opens for false
advertise that they're going to yell at me
but free and open source software is not as
good as you think everybody says 0 the
quality be better because everybody's
participating yeah and they're fucking spare
time
now there's some projects that are extreme
exceptions to that Lennox is one of them
because why because there's millions of
dollars of companies that are paying people
to support the software you get what you pay
for
you get what you pay for
and if you're not paying for a look there's
great right open source software but the
people who are volunteering a project look
I'm going to say something that's going to
get me in big trouble with the free and open
source people but I don't care this is the
thing
yeah there's a difference between
community-driven and open source so
I challenge you to find a single project
worth using it has been released under free
and open source
that is actually worth using that is
entirely created by Community volunteer
hours
it's all shit
it's all shit people it's all shit no
previous D is closed
Bitcoin is not community volunteers no no no
there that's a very capitalist sort of thing
to say look every single thing you've
mentioned as a company who is involved who
has a vested profit and take on it
need software in the free and open source
community that is being used and its
high-quality all of it has somebody is
saving or making serious money off of it
BJ's is kind of close, but they're all
really good stuff
so what I'm trying to say is I think that's
probably the closest one them is a good one
I like that one that was a good example
then this is a good example
I'm sure there are some out there but but
that means you could you could argue that is
so core and essential to so many people's
jobs every day that they make absolutely
sure that it gets fixed in a but if you
asked any of them people what they think of
him they would say oh that's more
community-driven shit that's not doesn't
have what we wanted it
so I mean that's the reason they made the
album is they don't think there's enough but
you know the currency is a thing only useful
for a single person that's not true at all
and you show me one definitive Source it was
made by a single person
yeah no no no that's a complete
mischaracterization of the oven vs Diaz
pretty damn close
I don't know i b s t is also the basis for
is it freezing FreeBSD as a basis for most
of the routers out there right
I I mean look Debian I think they're being
is pretty much all volunteers the people of
them impossible to it pretty much to name
any open source project right now that
doesn't have some company involved either
through paying the salary of somebody who's
contributing or through making direct
contributions that you could coincide this
very conservative position on this I would
suggest that you could go inside them is
pretty damn good
you can probably think you could probably go
inside the increase in open source software
adoption with the participation of companies
in open source software contributions and
I'll give him credit for it what I'm saying
is that it finally got them look a bunch of
as a perfect example of this canonical walks
in Mark shuttleworth who is not an
open-source guys like literally the polar
opposite of Richard stallman he comes
walking in and he says hey look what we're
going to do
we're going to make we're going to make his
words exactly we're going to make Linux a
viable desktop option
and he sold his soul to all kinds of people
to make it happen it in terms of capitalism
they are you like I need got a rod, they can
pick a partner and all this and that is when
you can you can almost trace the explosion
of desktop Linux as a viable option to Mark
so diverse creation of Ubuntu and everybody
thought he was crazy when he didn't anybody
who's old enough to remember the Linux days
pretty open to and posted 12 will confirm
what I'm saying
I hate to say this but Mark shuttleworth
gets credit for bringing Lennox into the
mainstream
so and the time for more permissive
commercial licences which dominates is what
made them explode the past 10 years I
completely agree with the bunnies I totally
agree
CERN open source I don't know that.
So yeah so far I think the best example of a
pure contribution to open source is probably
them but
a tour bash even you know get getget get
will get you
get get get get get it get in Lenox Lenox is
2 I mean
I don't know symetrix I personally can't
can't say get because I think it gets is
associate with Lenox I know you don't think
so
but no my job is disastrously bad don't
touch it
every other very unpopular opinion I hated
my job Rick my entire computer lab get up is
not open source
mothers get lab
when it says limited edition which is like
mostly Microsoft and big other companies
that run in programming languages I don't
know if we're grabbing languages count
arrest was made because they wanted language
for Mozilla or vice versa. No way with the
chicken the egg there
what happened I want nothing we're just
talking so yeah
yeah top Nissa there's look there's a ton of
tiny little projects that would qualify for
sure but I'm talking about like the major
things right
I like this music
hey you don't you can do whatever you want
with my girl if you have a good experience
with it I am people that I deeply respect
love my Jarl I hate it
much are literally bricked my entire
computer lab and all of my young kids I was
mentoring to computers when they clicked on
the upgrade icon 2 years ago I'll never
forgive him for it and then they screamed at
us and said you should have done the graphic
up South Africa up to UPS at the graphics
installer I was like really that's why I
guess we're going to go with us you're not
going to help us. They said no you should
have never known to do that I used to know
everybody everybody knows not to click the
graphic upgrade a button don't ever do that
that's stupid like well then why is it there
it is stupid updating is user yeah
yeah I would never touch our channel for
anything real
my truck has it seashells the fall other
perfect I have a stupid they are I'm sorry
if you actually think seashell is better
than Bosch you have to justify that
statement
do you have any idea how much shit is
missing from the show
I just I can't believe people do that I
can't they do I tried I tried it for a full
day I'll wait where is this wait where is
this way where is this way where is this
like while I do it because I can do CD
Pathways yeah but that means you don't know
what to say about people who switched a
seashell don't know bash and they make a
change is so fucking stupid know it's
absolutely not based on Bosch it's based on
Kay show
it's just so stupid it's so stupid and every
time I say it's stupid nobody nobody can
justify their choice of mash with if you
push I made I made so many resumes you shall
now every time and I actually tried it every
time I say these things I give him a
challenge I say tell me one reason I should
use the show it's a default on back I don't
want to mess with it
barely a reason barely a reason I bought
them under I'll barely reason and by the way
any any computer operating system that
chooses the shell as a default is made a
fucking moron Architects have decided to
totally thumb their nose at the
international standard running on trillions
of devices why would you do that I know why
because he's jealous Release Center MIT
license instead of being gplv3 that's the
honest-to-god reason that mon General and
the Apple do that because Montero has been
caught with his pants down so many times
trying to stick this Enterprise software on
its Distribution on Gerardo is trying to be
ample for Lennox the company has openly
proven that over and over again they are
trying to become an Enterprise version of
arch and they don't want any gplv3 on there
that's why people don't use Bosch if you
push them hard enough if
which companies that make the decision to do
this clean Apple if you push them hard
enough they'll stay home with them. If you
get to the bottom of it that the real reason
is the license because they are terrified of
you people be three and the way you know
that is because they hobbled Mack Mack, Mack
was BST 2.0 because it had a gplv2 license
4/5 years because they were too fucking
terrified of gplv3
that is the real reason
gplv3 you have to understand gplv3 gplv3 is
a disaster to disaster
yeah and you just go watch Linus Torvalds
talk about it he'll kill you everything you
need to know it's an absolute disaster
nobody should ever use it we have to use it
because the people that are riding Basher or
big proponents of it but nobody serious puts
anything when she filled me 3 in production
anywhere it's not use no that's actually one
of the reasons I think that
a lot of that stuff is being ripped off of
other stuff too with disrespect I don't care
what are you what's your what is your
district for servers or desktop
you like the task completion do you not know
about CD path
do you not know about CD path and Bash and
apparently not may I suggest anybody who
picks the most seashells users if you push
him on why they're using seashell they will
tell you it's because well all I see she
looks so pretty that ultimately they'll give
that up did you know the Z show project
itself came out against oh my seashell
I said please zshell project disease show
project said please please don't use on my
zshell
you're not going to go pick it up it's crazy
I like why are they doing I have no idea
you can do everything that you can do with
all my seashell and both i-parcel matching
instead of just about shovel back parcel
matching I hate that I hate that is super
dangerous by the way
yeah it's super dangerous I see people doing
that partial match used it all the time and
I'm like oh my God you really okay with that
have any idea how dangerous that is
I'm at I want to be precise in my use of the
terminal I don't want fuzzy finding I don't
want fuzzy matching and shit like that to
ruin my day and by the way why would you
ever want to burn that in your muscle memory
why would you want to burn using your
command line interaction like that all the
way people use fish do as fine but you do
what you want I don't want to be irrelevant
I want to get on any basket Man line and use
it boom and I know how to use it in my face
and my skills work everywhere and I'm able
to detect completion when I need to and I'm
able to see the end of this thing when I
need to we need to spend something fast he
was fine I would wrap or said or whatever I
don't I don't have the penalties on shit
that's not going to work everywhere because
I don't know where my containers going to
have it I'm usually going to be just a
little bit busy walks around fine or I'm
going to be on a stand her sister are going
to hack into some of this is why I don't
understand why people burn shit into their
muscle memory that only applies to their
customized homegrown highly configured
workstation I think it's stupid but if you
do it that's fine I don't think you're
stupid I think you have made a decision
based on your knees and that's totally
different I'm not calling you stupid
so and Bash demo mode
you don't need it that's what I'm trying to
tell you if you're using partial magic you
know you got different problems right yeah I
mean I don't need any of that stuff so
some people are comfortable with a
customizations are also comfortable never
using another computer that's why they used
Emax people that I highly respect never ever
leave one computer they stay on one they say
I want computer forever and they never leave
it mostly software developers scientist
people like that and they loved I prefer a
highly customized environment with all kinds
of shit that you can't do on any other
computer and so they have different needs if
that's the one that's what you want to do
that makes you more efficient fine I don't
care that she's not too I choose not to
violate the eunuchs velocity every time you
do that you're just throwing you a nice
place we have to fucking window I I just
don't want to do that I don't know yet I
think it's stupid I think I think is stupid
even for personal use but but people I love
and respect strongly disagree with me
alright so
let's see here let's go to fight me
somebody actually put something in fight me
bugs make it or did I turn on pictures in
here I guess I must have
then you ice a pissed-off Rob have fishes
and appalled
the fishes of the fishes fishes I tried
fishing one day and I was like why do people
like
where's why I hate and tell us it's how did
people use this thing how do people use
intellisense I don't know how to I do not
want shit to pop up all the time in my face
and try to give me a suggestion
if I want that I will push tab thank you
very much you know
I'm I'm off 410 completion and intellisense
ice or a sort of is
this is not a shell if it's a show and then
they called him back because their shells
and Bash that's fine it's just not the same
I didn't I tell you I think you're right no
no no what I'm I said I misspoke so
intellisense right intellisense the stabbing
right
so this is what I do when I'm actually for
so we were doing some sea coating the other
day
where do I see coding right
and somebody said you know you but you can
get to get up get them a right away and I
was like what the fuc
why would you go with intellisense when you
can get the whole fucking man page instantly
I go out of way at a capital K and I have
the whole fucking man page right there in
front of me why on Earth would you do
anything is frisky when it goes back
I don't want some trolling you know teasing
hint
I want the content I want to know what it's
about I do understand everything here I do
capital K I have that one doesn't have it
right so we have it down here made have it
this one so it let's go see if they'll give
me a yeah let's go let's go let's go to
print out okay all right there's print off
yeah here's print a Catholic a
it would do it again so it's I'm in here I'm
like looking at stuff that's supported I
want to read about four and a half
Alicia Padilla am no God no
I don't do that since I know you can do that
if you want. I just I want to be able to
type in a relatively okay with typing thing
is this actually works for other stuff too
so
so if you're right and go code right and you
want to know what Funk made is same thing
because it's on documented case of that
wasn't documented and go look at the import
importation document it what else is not,
this imprint of 970 from a long yeah and
that cool how many people know about that
how many people loaded up their neovim of
the bunch of shity on portable Lua plugins
to do what was already possible with with
capital K
it's okay I'm just wishing capital K I'm in
I'm in regular mode
and I do look at fmg okay here's fnt
packages under I say so get this one lands
on these doing is a Mets today
Carolina floor mats
Eric from asking using to file formats or
suffering of offerings by the law right so
yeah fronting memory I don't want my memory
from today
I don't
nipple docs yeah I don't want my memory from
today. I know people use it but I don't like
it I don't want my memory prompted I
personally don't think it helps you memorize
that. That would be some fun nuke I'm not
exactly but I would I would like to see some
sort of like neurological study about until
prompting versus memorization it could be
that intellisense is a good way to do a
factory recall and it's a good way to help
you remember
that could definitely be I could be I don't
know
if a cat's if possible how about python is
it doing a python
and yes I let me know what we want to talk
about the memory stuff I love you as good as
a 4-year up for what development I really
like this code
yeah I don't do that much was going to do
and when I do I usually use a preview or
which is just running all the time and just
auto updates every time I make any change
so that's just that's myself question what
is the best way to deal with mental block
can I don't know I don't really have a
specific answer for that intellisys for
Speed
feed you talking about for tab completion
yeah
is gravity games okay so let me first say I
am not a full-time software developer so the
people that I've seen people who used to
tell us Ence who like was vs code they can
use intellisense to generate entire files
like that
and they're very very very dependent on that
yeah autocomplete and God knows I am a fan
of autocomplete I just built it into my
whole system this thing here this is my own
version completion I'm a huge fan of Tampa
Bay's my life tool live till I did for me
changing my statuses and actually to sit
this is looking all these possible
completions I am a huge fan of
auto-completion and Snippets I'm a huge fan
of those things I just don't like using
their system I would prefer to use Unix
method the best auto completion and Snippets
system you will ever use is them
because anything any filter and eunuchs
filter that I can make something here
I can run I can run Snippets right from the
command line
the eunuchs filters are by far the best the
best snippet and auto-completion option you
have at your disposal if you are a very few
of them user it is far more powerful far
more flexible than anything at any ID can
give you the only thing and ID can give you
that's better which hands down if I were
doing any court dates over a thousand lines
of code I would consider using you Max of
something bigger than that it's things like
stuff that symbols you want to rename a
symbol across a massive codebase yeah good
luck doing that with Griffin said and not
blowing the world upright so there are very
specific cases where I totally think I would
never I don't know I'm always like hiking on
all the scripture or a little cold here
above a bla yeah are using ID for debugging
moving between files
yeah I don't I don't see why I would even
need to move that fast but you felt so I see
people do that and I'm not impressed with
their speed they think they're fast but I'm
like just closed the file their people with
people complain about me closing files and
reopening files with VI but it takes like
half a millisecond to do it
NyQuil and then I can just split up on the
screen but but I've seen
yeah yeah but why would you have 1,000 files
open or anywhere near that if you need to
get as I just said if you need to rename a
symbol
there's nothing but now there are ways to do
it and then there's that there's someone's
utilities for doing it that I've never
needed to use there are tools that will
rename all the symbols from the command line
have you said yeah it's a lot faster than
crap
I have too much that I have to close a file
realtor another yeah yeah that's one of the
reasons I used too much if I can if I want
to files open
what I have done because I'm working on a 20
year old classic Legacy Cove Base yeah if
you have if you have I don't know why I
would have that many files open but as I
said I already said I am not working on a
huge go base the people that I know that I
really respect who do this work way more
than me they use an IDE when they have to
wait till you see the email where they use a
vehicle code or virtual Studio or some form
of like large ID and the only time I've ever
missed a large ID is when I need to
visualize a really long file I learn to
search through it and stuff or when I needed
to change a symbol it's like if you need to
change a symbol name and every fucking thing
needs to change right there are command line
tools for that but I don't use them all the
time I also don't code massive master code
basis I don't work on a very much I mean if
I did I usually I select the one thing I
want to work out
get that function to work and then and then
bring it in but the people who Bill Billy
who build really large things like like like
games is he fussing stuff like that I I
would be definitely on board because they
have to compile on top of everything else
you can pilot a C+ Plus game development
trying to do that from the command line
would be fucking torture and that would be
torture I just I watch yct all the time with
the C plus plus
the C plus plus game. I don't like no this
is this is this is when you want an ID and
so you know I'm not against I use I just I
just from most nine times out of 10 I don't
you know I don't need it
I mean it is a more space app
I know you dropped alacrity alacrity cuz I
had too many bugs it's buggy alacrity is
really buggy I finally had to just own it I
was like trying so hard to apologize for it
and I got ready I might know fuck it
especially at windows I tried to run on
Windows was such a disaster especially if
you can if you're full screen to get any
kind of notification from Windows alacrity
is like totally fucking screws up it's
actually dangerous because you don't know
where your tattoo could be you could be in
the middle of a really important project and
you get a notification in full screen while
a curry is on in your your screen is
immediately tanked and you're like oh shit
where was I I don't know what to do it's
dangerous is downright dangerous I won't use
it see tax
naturalist if you could do you have any
information about ctags I've been to Texas
what I'm missing because I mean people wrote
the original Unix and Linux kernel ucbi did
they didn't have E-maxx back then I mean I
did a bunch of the Gucci Museum but people
have been working on the colonel using
Sea-Tac have been 4 years
so the battle of the tab button oh my God
that would be cool that would be cool yeah
and changing variables the variable names
over multiple files is crucial absolutely I
think that one reason alone honestly I think
that one reason alone it really is worth it
I really do I think that's not resolve by
itself is worth it so I can't get it I I
don't need it it's it's an overwhelming to
me but but for people who really know their
software development they they need an ID
and I don't I don't I don't like that I'm
not I don't think anything bad about him for
dinner
is a schema last essential Linux valve valve
index Under lyrics
I don't know what that means valve steam has
blue steam is the only application that has
literally Frozen my computer more than once
running Linux and it's done at this point
it's been at least a dozen times man playing
a game or something and using steam and
Lennox it totally kills my thing is we are I
don't know I'm not into VR
I need to find I need to learn how to use
eat eggs
people been telling me that you see takes
forever and I have no fucking idea to do it
it's not just a silly thing right
did you empty symbolism in
Dothan tag system yeah I need to learn that
I've never I've never done that I need to
learn it
I really do I got really good at searching
the reason I like see text because I think
it I think it messes with my I have a search
Centric method of editing things rather than
trying to remember all the keystrokes and
everything I just searched for everything
and it just me to the thing tonight and I'm
always thinking about the unique word that's
going to get me to the thing I don't need to
find so that's my style I'm I really like
see tags I think I would really benefit from
learning and I don't I don't know what no I
don't even know where to get it
bootstrap Steven of EMC don't affect your
home machine with pastor and everything fuck
no way too much work
I'm too I'm too yeah
I have getting the terminal and all my stuff
is in one place yeah a lot of people do like
that and that's actually why I used to have
to get her start with Ds code they like
having it in the terminal they don't like
fucking with it and everything and they like
another reason they like it is because it
comes with all the color schemes
automatically built-in you don't have to
fuck around with that you have to deal with
like what like means is that he was go pick
one there's a lot of reasons to go to the
Great Piece of software I just think it's
too slow one day I was trying to get my
buddy gave to the tribe Bas code instead of
them do you know pretty much time as I know
like yet I'm not going to do that because I
work with python all day I'm not going to
wait around for them to start up a few only
start at once and then just keep it running
as you're going to be so you're telling me
you're advocating to have been an electron a
running all the
iPhone app running all the time in your
computer
and I started to think I was stupid it was
and I was like no I don't want to. He's
right he's up to the right and I went back
to VI and I never look back
and the biggest thing you give up with vs
code is you cannot use Unix filters you
can't do it
you can't do it I mean you can use them in
the terminal B that way you might as well
just use a terminal if that's not BS go to
that point
yeah you can pretty much handing off your
learning plugins and shit in rather than
using unit filters and I think it's such a
tragedy a so many are they School developers
are throwing out the Unix Philosophy for
monolithic IDs and and they don't need them
and they're not even Destin they're not even
trying to become software Engineers they're
trying to become something else so epic 3D
content creation be at Stacy's and Lenox
a day that I didn't even manage to get a
disc to play and I don't know if I would be
doing that though in the first place
if if arches bad what cells are different
song everything by myself even the gooey
the arch is the one I would pick if you want
to do then yeah you can do a Debbie and if
you want
I don't I guess it look if you're going to
build your own OS I would use Arch and I
have when I was when I was getting ready to
do hack the Box
I was doing at the box and I said fine I'm
going to build my own I was like people
recommending parrots and I tried that I was
like no Kelly is like this is way too much
shit I would never use what's Unix filter if
you don't know what you getting Spencer is
then you need to read about tunics paucity
yeah yeah here's some stuff I did not
he can go read about it if you don't know if
you need filters at the debt the Boost by
the way
the Boost the 2021 moose I kind of obsessed
about filters about 2 weeks in China did I
spent way too much time teaching people how
to do unit filters if you want to see those
used in bi
I can go look at Ya Magic
I will show you how to do it's it's all
about filters you can use the filter you
don't know the filter command in Vi at 6.8
time using! It's called the filter command
and VI people don't know it its most
powerful thing in behind they don't know
I use it all the time
I do a lot of things at when I need to do
building refactoring ago but I think that's
the way to go I think Nick somebody's I
think that's what I would do too
that's how I that's probably if I were built
we're going to be her project yeah I think
that's why I make it sometimes you want to
just jump into terminal in like do Searcher
command line or you want to crawl down a
file them it is annoying things you might
want to do from the terminal via code at
least has a built-in Sublime did all the
other editors never had a built-in terminal
at I think that's really what put vs coat
over the top and beat everybody out the
thing that made me his code win over all of
the other lightweight editors was because it
included a terminal
and I know that that's the reason I picked
it over brackets and and it was the other
one all the other ones
yes, struggling with big ones you have I
don't think I would use you as code for like
I seen a massive C plus plus database like
the fifty thousand and fifty million lines
of office or whatever the fuck that window
Windows developer you're pretty much stuck
with virtual Studio I did that for a while.
I hated it
because bases yeah
what did you use for big code bases with the
asking what did you end up using because
that's not my my realm of expertise
I mean the only time I would use in a big
coat base was to go find where the bugs were
under with Tivoli
I would like to have to find where all the
bugs are with Stitch it would crash and send
it to their level support had to go take it
out
they hate a little studio in a couple things
I love ya
what are things I love about virtual studio
is the extremely Dynamic real time sharing
of a screen wire developing for
all things for Education that's like really
really amazing you can do the same thing
with teemix and there's all sorts of too
much tools to do that but for the average
person install via Studio sent him a link
and you've got interactive to tivity it's
actually really great for education but
I mean it's all going through their servers
and stuff's not secure at all but
it is for the average person I think it's a
really great way to do Metairie if if you're
like for example if you were going to get
into code mentoring
I think getting the person who if you would
like quote your mentoring somebody else who
has no idea how to do stuff at all I think
that's a good idea
I think it's a good idea because you can
share with them and you can tell them what
what they need when they can do to can help
them or directly and it's very easy you just
that install the S code and boom you're
pretty much sharing you sent him a link and
your sharing system either that or a webpage
like replicate replicate replicate you can
do I can share on to as actually probably
better these days if they have web access if
you're just meant for any one person then it
concerns like having a consistent internet
connection or buying to make you can make it
to expectations like that you can't do that
if you're teaching a school class with 30 or
40 spoons at the same time who all have to
use the system I don't at the hard way I
have learnt the hard way I almost crashed
and burned at a private school because their
internet was not good enough and I had to
have them all so obvious code and we did
everything locally we had them all install
web preview software
browser sync on to their laptops
and they saw browser preview software so
they could work on their game locally and
preview it using browsersync and they did
not need anything more than be as cold and
browsersync they didn't even need an
internet connection at all and if you're
ever dealing with unreliable internet that's
our only option is a teacher you can't
really do more than that unfortunately to do
that you have to have admin access and I had
two or three people in the group who did not
have admin access on their computers and it
said you need to tell your parents you need
admin access so you can install these things
and if so can you just tell me what to
install I said know if you're going to be in
this class you need to have your parents
give you admin access on a computer that
they trust you to have admin access on all
the way to get the fuck out
it was so annoying like but my parents don't
trust me. I don't give a shit if you're
going to be here you have to have admin exit
boot camps with low and hardware and ID on
the browser yes
if the internet is good or host in Atlanta
if your computer is good yeah the whole the
whole hosting you could host it on the land
but that's no that's not an option that's
reliable for a lot of people you have to set
it up if too much that up
and even he tries to get him or no thanks I
know the one you're talking about life so
yeah it's not good unless they fix it they
stopped support of it years ago
years ago they stopped support of it they
wasn't and they didn't have any updates to
it it's pretty good it's pretty good but I
hopefully they picked up support of it again
maybe not I think it's still my favorite
because it's been maintained its really
really solid it does everything in real time
yeah we had to admit I was using leftover
for long time it was easier to install the
browser think you just you know you just you
just did selling it right and
but I don't know if life server is still
supported it at the time my server had been
dropped out of support and then they so I
did feel liable
ring a triplet yeah I love rap what I told
you my whole thing was rough but we talked
about that before right at my whole back and
forth with I'm John on that I have probably
the top hit on raffle it out there on Google
if you Google it explain the problem with
replicas
I love rough but I think it's been tested
for students I think it's great for sharing
I love love love it the only thing it did
and I started teaching my class on replicate
the problem with red fluid is that it has to
have a solid internet connection is a
real-time terminal
and uses real-time editing if it makes me
you if you had any hiccup in your internet
at all your fucked can you imagine waiting
around for your keystrokes
keystrokes slower than if you were using as
a safe room as a server in Russia or
something
I know she's so far yeah life server it just
can you check to see if you if you happen to
come around again next time use it just
looking to see if it if it if they remove
good morning
they just have a warning on the side to side
this this project is no longer supported
Baba blah if you're still using it I imagine
it's been removed and somebody picked it up
that's good news because it's way easier to
use that you just put the plug-in on your
done right by the way if you if you want to
get kids coding right away the fastest thing
to do is to just put vs coat on and that's
it don't even use get her get Hub let them
sort of stuff on the home computer we did I
did this I took a gamble cuz I wanted to
just let me know when you're lost time with
ruffle it so I did not have them learn get
and get home and we had one girl loser whole
project
her computer crashed and she lost everything
but most of the kids that are using their
computers for school are at risk of losing
their entire world at any moment anytime
because their computers are everything they
don't they have a USB stick and maybe they
have USB sick but they do not have a copy of
anything anywhere so if their computer dies
their fucked they're totally done
what's that promise was Chromebooks and how
God
are using the old Chromebooks that don't let
you reimburse them we tried so hard we had a
girl who had a Chromebook and we tried so
hard to give you ass go to work on that for
her as she was really smart she was probably
one of the smartest in the crowd and we
could not do it we cannot get it to work a
code
I think I heard that they had changed since
then they've made it start to work but maybe
not they got via schedule run in the browser
now but then you got the internet problem
again right
I noticed that's what Leon's new in liana's
is having people use vs code in the browser
and like okay
I think I think promoting someone to have
internet dependencies during their
development is borderline irresponsible
because we have so many of the question hey
binary put you on
and come talk to us invite to speaker
I don't know how my sound is working are you
there
check one two how's that going
did you set did you want to say something or
participate if not you're fine
game the binary chaos has voice now so just
saying
oh did you have to okay
yeah me too
yeah
well I I I love France so you know right
away it sounds like you do you work in the
edge you work in the education space than
you
34 like $6,000 no more but I mean it'll
limit so much what you can do with it
because you're like when it comes to that
teaching a form of technological competency
limiting
yeah yeah it is
teach kids some Basics and logical thinking
in and
encoding and you we can't do that because
yeah
yeah that's true at what are your thoughts
on on you know Apple trying to get everybody
on the iPad 4 to learn how to code
size as the United States
so go running
Windows XP
I think it was really like a budget a budget
decision to switch to Google and yeah I
think that's usually what it is is they
don't have the money and
you know I don't know what to say I I I got
out of it though because it was so
frustrating same in Australia
around and
where am I reach my eye with end we're like
now I'm looking into doing something else
something else yeah well that's just a quick
verse repeated my story so I started
to get this and get your disenchanted with
what I was doing as a corporation you know
drone and and I wanted to help out so I made
friends with the educational community on
Twitter actually and it was one person to
take her to reach out to me and said hey
there's this thing called lateral entry in
America you can become a teacher if you want
to do FasTrak you to get your thing and I
went down that path for about a year
add at the end of it I concluded that
I was going to be more frustrated doing that
than ever because I was going to be you know
out a certain amount of money I was going to
be making less money I was going to be
frustrated by fighting against the school
system that forced me to teach Java AP
Computer Science and inheritance and all
this other stuff I would have almost no
latitude in the classroom to teach what I
wanted to and there was no way I was ever
going to be able to get the money to buy the
resources that I wanted to I went to iste
International Society for technology
education and there was a prisoner there who
had managed to you know get on the national
map because he's gotten so many grants he
built that magnet school for 3D modeling and
everything everybody wanted to go to his
school when he had a really great set up
because he had written all these grants and
but has he got talking about it
the only thing I could think about was how
much work he had to do just to get what
should have already been okay to set up and
was like constantly fighting against the the
status quo
it's always we are public servants Play We
and is it going to be good for that for
everyone as opposed to being a catering to
maybe you're your own schools now yet
moderately high-income yeah yep
social economics
notify
cool
like it's not Equitable around the whole
board then we're Limited in what we can and
cannot do
curiosity were you but you say that you were
teaching me yes
yeah I did a little of all of it I was kind
of trying to find my way so
the first thing I did was I started my own
what do they call an instructional
technology company called Ed Tech Retreat or
actually I wanted the teachers and I made a
company and we we we didn't rear-end support
we made it. We did second life virtual
worlds and open SIM and we gave
presentations on the ad and hosted and we
were really pushing 3D environments as a as
an alternative for learning a new remote
learning I had for teachers to get together
and celebrate so that was the first thing I
did and then that went away and it's
spectacular way that I won't talk about I've
been watching long enough you know what
happened there for anybody is wondering if
cheating with her leaving the Mormon Church
destroying the whole company and trying to
pick up my life after that because it was so
amazing I wanted to help out and it was
actually helping out and so I know that's a
if that's the drama there I had people are
wondering what they've heard me talk about
work and so then I went into I tried to
recruit
in an effort after the divorce in and a
friend of mine said hey go teach the summer
camp I know you still like education so I
taught this gaming summer camp that was the
first time I taught a class and then after
that I was like man I can get into this
education things Rector web do that by the
gaming things that needed to come teach us
so I talked to the community colleges and
add hunk I had Hawk and I develop their web
curriculum and it was my first official job
in education and immediately I want to get
out of that because half the people fail
then I was like I talk to my director is
like half the people are failing and they're
like yeah that's fine
like what yeah there was a fine I'm fine is
that this is any good dude most of them were
just here cuz they're going to get their VA
benefits and they have to do the minimum
it's not you they don't care they just want
to be more like why am I doing this that the
whole you know the whole point of of being
there was taking me so that meant I need to
make a change I retired early sort of
retired are they taking a big of Chuck on
retirement money out starting skill Sac
right now for 8 years and in the middle of
that I helped several other school start
their own programs their own after school
programs I I would do in a different things
as soon as we can help me to see what help
Scout Troops and it we would try to see.
Other things so I got to a real exposure to
how other schools were challenged by the
simple thing like how do we teach coding and
so I was kind of an ad hoc and something to
drink a Time
they brought me on to be a consultant and
advisor curriculum specialist for for a
couple different schools and one that was
doing a 12-12 computer for and then
eventually the end actually it's still sick
I thought well hey let's try this so I I had
the the president of a private school call
me it's safe we hear you're the guy at 2 to
do this come over and make a program for us
and he kind of flattering me is really
amazing dude I really loved working with him
and so I said fine so I taught there for two
years after that. They're they're extra is
an extra-curricular coding program at a time
an elite pro 2 of Friends School here and
everybody had their own computer is all one
that won the kids weren't particularly
better than anybody else but I did I
experience that just had a lot of money in
there was a private school
and then that was pretty much it after that
I toyed with the coming of professor at one
point and then I quickly shut that down
because the amount of bureaucracy and stuff
that is even better is even worse so VA
benefits that's it
VA benefits that sits a VA benefits in me
while she is a thing in America if you serve
the military you can qualify for veterans
benefits but if you don't have a job you
have to do minimum things like unemployment
and community colleges in America are a lot
of times there to help people that are
unemployed for whatever reason try to get
work and that includes the veterans and so
what they do is
it's not everybody and it's really it's
really unfair to characterize it this way
but but the director told me that at that
particular Community College that I should
not think that a 50% failure rate was a bad
thing because most of the people there those
were his words were only there to do the
minimum required to get their paycheck
they pay for your bachelor's versus idea I
was his statement I don't mean to
mischaracterize Veterans by any means but I
didn't want to be involved in anything where
the people that were that I was working with
did not want to learn once I started my own
private thing and for minor that's one of
the things I recommend if you're thinking
about starting up something on the side
maybe keeping her day job but
slowly working toward putting together a
mentoring you know Surfside company
I kind of yeah I like that actually almost
got a master's in instructional design
because I do like that I like organizing
content not good at it I'd like to hang it
but if
yeah
yeah the education
yeah that's that's why I did it right
because I it's still it's a core part of who
I am I can't not do it I sometimes I resent
it more than other days but if I don't do it
I go crazy if I if I had to sit back and
look at the state of our world and just
accept it and do my day job and not try to
do anything about I go insane I would
actually go insane and it's it's it's
actually kind of selfish because I could not
I cannot sit back and watch this educational
or will crumble around us without at least
trying to fight for a better way it would
make me insane more than I already left so
so I keep trying I keep trying to find
something better I keep a change my mind all
the time and it's already my time also the
content changes all the time
I was like what are you teach right it's
like
it's like like an exponential problem I have
like I change my mind all the time and the
content is constantly changing I mean the
stuff you need to know
yeah
you're already starting to flesh out as I
wasn't being rude is going to look like for
this year
what it looks like now looks like yeah I was
trying to do that that's actually one of the
things I've enjoyed is I've been able to
experiment when you own your own company you
can experiment with what works and what
doesn't and you can leave like it it's not
working you can change it that's actually
the freedom that I I really like and how it
sits it can be frustrating when people
trying to keep up but
but so that's that's kind of where where I'm
going I thought the whole
choose-your-own-adventure thing might be a
fun thing to try I've always wanted to do
that then people want consistency they want
to be linear and they also want badges in
one project-based learning they want all of
that and how do we bring it all together you
know I feel like this idea of the main quest
in the side quest thing is something I want
to keep cuz it kind of keeps at least the
spirit of all of the original ideas of this
this year anyway
yeah
right specialized
yeah yeah
yeah that's a huge change for me I
if I've constantly been trying to check cuz
I was going to a sec I had to pick how many
people per class I would have right and I
started out with eight and then I went and I
realized three was the magic number and it
made a big deal about that three was the
magic number I used to joke about being able
to like its arms line so I can wack them you
know if they got out of line and they could
be friends and everything I tried I was
trying to find the optimal learning
environment you know I had the freedom to do
whatever I wanted
so I experiment with lots of things I had a
classroom full of 16 people and we had a
blast and I made crazy tons of money and
nobody learned a thing you know because we
were School programming and they were all
pushing each other in different ways and Sir
kids were checking out is that so they
finally got to go down smaller 393 I found
out with three even three people would even
three people you have a class in this was
the hardest thing of all
if you're teaching to a class you have a
different curriculum and a different
approach from teaching a single person
and that was the biggest break so I had that
came through in 2008 to 2019 I want to say
to kids at a Time Sweet Spot I used to think
two kids who is it was a time and then okay
so I actually went to imma give you I'm
going to tell you to tell me a little story
about this okay that it's just an attic
though it's not scientific but yeah so you
think competition is a good thing until it's
not okay you think it is right so the
codeine text deals whatever so I went to two
people per class and I had
I have two stories related to this this this
or that these these two experiences actually
convert convince me that the only thing I
ever wanted to do was do you want to one
after that and the reason I'm talking about
this at all these binary just brought up the
fact that I'm trying to adapt that approach
to 22 sharing with thousands of people at
the same time and it's it's obviously
different right I think a big piece of this
year the tldr is I try to speak to one
person at a time as if they were me and them
one-on-one the problem is is that
as soon as you have two people you have two
personalities you have to learning styles
you have to learning rates you have two sets
of of of you know capabilities and aptitudes
that are different and you know I used to
think that competition was a good thing and
I used to think that having no friends
together is a good thing and I'll meet all
the reasons that is wrong so and if you
still want to try this great but it's very
very rare very rare yes that is exactly what
happened on U Guessed It you guessed it I
had a kid who had been with me this is this
app actually has a third story of this this
is the three stories of how the two people
together ultimately all destroyed each other
they just imploded completely I lost people
from it so okay so did the number one
assumption is I'm going to take two people
that are best friends and they're just going
to get along and we could be fine they're
best friends right
well if you've ever had a best friend you
know that ultimately you're competing with
your best friend right so we can go see
people in there and they're both doing their
thing and I would spend time with one in the
other and the competition eventually kind of
you know started to be be an issue and and
it just wasn't nothing but the worst one of
all I had one guy who I've been there when
the young guy who'd been there for 3 years
andand he invited his his
they have this competition is this academic
competitions they're called the what are
they knowledge bowls or whatever just guys
good till it really kid
and so this other kid invited him to be to
come in I told them hey look you need to
find a friend if you can find a free, so it
was brand new he was ready to so they could
have been here for 3 years and he was
brand-new and the other kid Ben do the
minimum kind of kid the whole time he didn't
do anything except for what he did that one
out of his with us and and even then he
didn't really care about what he was doing I
mean he he did pretty good he was a nice guy
and everything but he just needs it wasn't
really into it but he still wanted to come
he was really into he really thought he
wanted to come and his parents wanted to
come so he kept coming so he invites his
friend is very first time and he obviously
naturally gravitate store it he's so good
that within three weeks the other kid drops
out permanently and never came back
because then his friend that he invited was
so much naturally better than him at doing
it that it was overwhelming and destroyed
his confidence to destroy his he going he
dropped out and when that happened I haven't
did I stayed for a long time because one of
my best people he stayed forever and noticed
he was nice having his acquaintance
everything but that was that is not
something I want to happen I don't want
somebody to leave thinking they're a bad
person that actually happened and so that's
the one that's the one negative about bring
two people together the other negative is I
had to phenomenally awesome people when was
a very very aggressive brilliant guy who's
actually on full scholarship down someplace
very very competitive and everything and I
paired him with a the daughter of a data
science professional who is a college
student
and they were in every way compatible
intellectual and capability wise but he when
he got into a situation with one other
person he would stop on what she said he
would take over the conversation he would
brag about his accomplishment big with her
in the room and I don't know what was going
on I don't know if internally he was trying
to pick her up or impress her impress me or
whatever but she left she didn't want
anything to do with it and she tried really
hard to make that a better situation to try
to have her come on the OWN
do you want me to do with it and and I feel
really bad about that because I have a lot
of women that I have taken through this the
program and they has been a very empowering
to them but in that case I feel like she got
bored to death you know the guy that did it
he's he's such a nice guy wasn't anything
you did intentionally it wasn't trying to be
mean he's just his personality he's just
very very competitive and and he's in soaked
but you know everything's competition to him
and he was always crazy amazing things and
she did crazy amazing things she's actually
the reason that I realize that python did
really horrible concurrency she just asked
how can I have a Wandering mushroom Python
and is like ridiculously hard compared to
JavaScript is that she was actually really a
really good person if she wasn't one of them
are regulars but that parent was the total
disaster that was a total disaster and he
stayed and went on to do amazing things and
she left
and the other one is two and two people my
very first two people okay my very very very
first two people these kids were best
friends and they were really best friends
they were young and they were Ben and I
couldn't get them to focus they were the
opposite there were such good friends that
would come to me after school I was like I
just stopped playing and they would show me
Carl the Llama I know about all these memes
in ancient things you know because of them
they would but they also have the coffee
shop you know and and they were like they
were trying to call all my God they do
something okay we're going to go now and
they did not I could not I could not get
those two to focus I cannot get into this I
cannot get him to focus all I wanted to do
is play with memes on the big screen and
stuff that's why I had to come by learning
style to say hey let's go to me or something
I actually because of them I try to figure
out a more engaging ways to bring what they
were interested in into the thing so I would
adapt as okay what name should we coated in
and let them drive it and they will laugh
what's up the whole time but they'd get some
code in and they were brilliant they were
the ones who hacked them my friends coffee
shop by just looking at the default password
really want to go over there this Friday
they're smart kids they were my mites on my
first two and then the other admitted that
it was a constant challenge it but if those
two probably wouldn't have come if they had
had to be in their one-on-one because they
would have been too boring they were doing
it because it was so fun to be together and
play and all that stuff so so they they were
going to a different energy and the last the
last one I'll say probably two of my
smartest I'm talking about a genius smart
okay not necessarily practical smarts to one
of the one of the boys I won't say who
what are the boys when they're their mom and
dad they knew they were their child was
smart but after I evaluated them and saw the
scratch project and that the that they
wanted to do pythons a gorean theorem on the
first day even though they were like under
12 I was like I was saying I was like
literally shaking cuz I was I was so in all
of the rod Genius of this kid and and I
actually told the parents I said it would be
my honor should be able to try to help your
son learn so anyway you fast-forward four
years after you've been with us for a long
time and and that boy I paired him with
another Super Genius will he may actually be
listening right now so I got to be careful
who is off of Columbia now and is like a big
big this guy did cancel for calculus for fun
and I said okay these two are going to be
fantastic together I mean cuz they were
naturally interested in the same things and
everything put them together
I know you know what happened this is what
happened with them both of them were really
brilliant they're really smart they were
they enjoyed having some comradery because I
don't know how many friends I had outside of
that group they drink a little bit of that
but putting them together slowed both of
them down
you think putting together with a fish spear
them up at didn't they both want to do
different things in different ways and they
didn't want to stay on the same topic they
were fascinated with different things and
they they had to be stimulated true
intellectual stimulation and they weren't
always interested in the same thing as
saying that fact very rarely they were and
they were very polite about it and they did
whatever I told him they would work together
as fine but this is what I did I said
finally to try something I didn't experiment
I had both of them come one on one and one
of the boys and me both of them progress but
one of the boys did in 1 hour what would
have taken is five sessions before in fact
he was so fast at being able to digest the
information that I could I could you know
five or ten times the rate at which I taught
because I was one-on-one and there was
nothing between us it was just he and I and
so his learning shot through the roof
now the other guy is still had the same base
learning you're so brilliant and did a lot
of things but had to focus on other issues
for him I had to focus on hey you need to
start capturing you know you're learning and
writing it in so you can show it off and
call it just something that we had other
issues that we had talked about so totally
brilliant we would have you would just want
to sit in the shoot the shit about about
machine learning and what it was doing and
tell me about the algorithm says have a try
to keep up and he just wanted somebody to
talk to about it that was what he needed the
other one was just just wanted to eat
everything up all the new stuff and so the
total gross or net the net gain the net
progress between these two was over the roof
when I separated them in fact it took me
more time to do it but the total amount of
learning and this is what's counterintuitive
about all of this if counterintuitive
thinking about moving to 101 education is
that we're going to lose time and money by
doing it I'm telling you I'm here to tell
you that if I were to go get a PhD or
something I would do a study on that
specific thing because I
the feeling that if you were to take all the
teachers and all the schools and you were to
say we're going to move to 101 education I
think the total gross amount the net amount
of learning progress would be higher because
there would be people that will earn more
slowly but they would not be holding back
the other people who could learn twenty
times as much in the same amount of time
probably
and then it'll go backright
so it's really really interesting that your
your your stories of what it's like to teach
in a semi-private for a setting or
yeah
try to show off yeah
there's actually one other kid there's go
ahead
I was just going to say there's one other
kid one of the key was a big brother big
brother and a sister and that was actually
toxic he saw that his sister was going
faster than him and he sabotaged our
progress
he would he would deliberately screw with
her screen and touch your keyboard and stuff
I had to kick him out
because his level of competition he was like
Not only was he not okay with her learning
in her own pace and having to be faster than
him but he said no she's not going to learn
faster than me I'm going to stop it and he
would he would he was seriously he was
constantly in her face and poking her and
you know I was like okay we're done here
yeah
right yeah yeah and I don't know if that's
the case I mean you know it's very Southern
family and she was adopted she wasn't you
know even the same races or adoptive family
and it is it's that actually I had to stop
and I was really pissed cuz she was really
really really into it and she was
fuckingawesome out of it and she paid the
price actually so I you know if you're going
to get into mentoring you have to have
kind of a thick skin because you're going to
be dealing with parents and situations and
people that at the end of the day you can't
just say I mean imagine teachers that teach
classrooms have the same issue but for me it
without that's one of the reasons that you
know that I struggled because you have to
deal with different types of the ice that's
why I had an hour-long interview before I'll
even bring somebody in because I was like I
don't this is a long-term commitment to this
individual I don't want to create a
relationship that's going to become toxic in
anyway and I kind of would try to nip those
in the bud before they happened in as it as
a private nature you have that option I feel
I used to talk to the teachers and they said
if you want to help us help the children and
the family situations of the children
because that's what we get stuck and dealing
with all the time that's what's impeding
their learning is the issues that are
outside of our control
and you know what you do with that right so
how can I record from home
yeah
tell a lie and there's always those parents
who think they think that that they are kid
needs to learn the way they did
and they're not willing to consider
alternate ways of learning or even the fact
that their child learns differently than
them
you know sure
yeah well I can I can I can describe a
little bit quickly by everything I'm about
to describe something I tried to put into
what I call this sustainable open
Independent Learning initiative soil have
logo and everything I was trying to capture
the Lessons Learned just from the hard way
you know from the 38 years and that's
probably that might be a book that I
actually do right and none of its
objectively in a pair of you is not a
scientific and any means that she is my
Impressions and Lessons Learned is so the
the first thing I'll say is that if
anybody's listening right now and you want
to start your own Mentor by the measuring
Community private tutoring if you want to
call it that I don't like that word but
these are the things that I learn so the
first question you asked was
how much time and what kind of relationship
did you set up with him will the first thing
is you never ever know
how long something's going to last but I
learned when I first started huge mistake
the first mistake I made was doing what I
thought was the right thing by only charging
them for they sessions they came to
huge mistake because they felt like if they
didn't come to a session they were going to
pay they would cancel at the last minute and
I would say okay are you going to come this
week it was an overwhelming administrative
nightmare on my head because I tried to
write all kinds of systems for to say okay
you going to be here here here's your
attendance here's your bill for your
attendance and I tried to do that hey walk
in and pay as you go that was a disaster do
not to do that so then I moved to pay by
month
they would pay for a month at a time I tried
to do the ticket thing or they would buy for
and then it come whenever they wanted to but
then I could get him to come consistently I
couldn't be sure I can't guarantee how much
income I was going to have during a given
amount of time and I got rid of that so
slowly and slow and slowly added up sort of
adopting a semi semester thing is so that I
could survive as well as them and that
became okay we have this class it runs for
you know you by sick with you know it starts
on this date and it goes to the state and
the problem with that is you can't take in
new people
so you can't you said you have new people
right well one of they come in and see you
try to stagger them and you have different
sessions during the week and you tried but
you you're only teaching a small number of
people you have so many hours during the day
so you can't have staggered semesters
interspersed with each other because it it
screws it up because you have like one
person story on this date and it well you
got to wait and pay us till this time and
then come in and so what my ultimate Lee and
then and then I was like okay will do we do
one or two at a time and then I went to the
one on one model and I said look at your if
you're going to sign up with me you're going
to get enough information to make a decision
about whether we want to be here for at
least three months and that meant 16
sessions and you get two sessions for free
so it was 16 sessions and to absolutely free
right off so that dealt with you know
holidays and everything and I charge 50
bucks a session and you know they were on
the calendar and each person was scheduled
out and they paid in advance so I had the
money and no matter what I had a no no
refunds policy is like if you pay this money
and if for any reason you can't do it or I
can't do it I'm sorry and it I don't even
know if it's legal but I was like you were
saying and blood that if either of us has a
situation you'll get we're just going to
accept and they said fine it's worth the
risk and if it's if I don't do it and you
and I and I had enough people backing me up
to 10. Should I do it yet to do that I would
actually be able to be late for for snow
storm reasons or something like that in a
case that's okay we're closed today because
of snow every time that happened I would
lose about 500 bucks by the way and I would
pay and I stop doing that
the snow storms why do I have to pay the
bill for having a snow storm these are
things that school is bigger schools don't
have to deal with it as a young but if
somebody's trying to manage your money after
you so I found that
16 weeks of Esther's was the best way to go
and I allowed people to sign up anytime as
long as it was a free hour slot during the
week and then that I couldn't take more than
40 people a week if you do the math you know
I did five people a day on Monday Wednesday
and Friday I did eight and is sometimes six
people on Saturday and Sunday eventually
dropped Sunday but I only charge 50 bucks a
month and you can do the math there that's
not very much money for year and barely
barely cracking them around 80 to 82 and
ninety thousand a year during that time but
I felt like it was it was worth it for the
benefit I also had my days to myself so
because there was nobody want to send it to
I sometimes I would take an adult during the
day or two or three but that's why I
supplemented with a private school thing
during the day and also we're going other
coding projects during the day then
hopefully things would make money
and so so that that was that was on that
went an app that actually was the best of
all of them people if somebody didn't want
to commit and pay 8 or $900 which is what it
was then it's probably not for them having a
big price tag to them they thought it was a
big price I let people think paying $800 to
learn coding
yeah
it was fifty bucks then I get the math wrong
or was it it was like 50 is 50 bucks
I'm finished I got this right maybe we can
write $800 / yeah that was it
yeah yeah
for an hour
everybody I talked to said I wasn't charging
enough and I was charging but I deliberately
charged a low rate because I wanted to get
people there and I did I have I had one
family sell a ton of stuff from their home
so their kid could be there and I had other
families travel in a 40 minutes every week
to be there I deliberately kept my price is
ridiculously low relatively and it was still
too much I can't believe how many people
told me that was too much money and I was
like okay you know I do but that meant your
your filter making it into a lump sum like
that was nice because that
gave you can type questions anywhere you
want to ask questions yet cuz I've been here
or go to just go to whatever there's no rule
here
so that that's what I like that's what I did
and I know that was not refundable and and
that doesn't count the two free things they
got so they actually got another $100 out of
me basically so so yeah I mean I don't know
if I would do it I fully believe if I were
to do it again I would be much much more
selective I would maintain some other part
time job it's not a full-time job and I
would I would double or triple the rate
the problem with that is that then you're
only getting people that either one have
tons of tons of money you get entitled
people who have tons of money who still
don't value it you think that by charging
money a lot of money you're going to get
people that are only going to be two that
want to be there
and I found out the hard way that's not true
entitled people who have a lot of money do
not value it no matter how much it cost and
I've had to deal with tons of these types of
people because they're the kind of people he
knows he owes the bank since they're the
kind of people that tend to want to put more
into their kids learning which is really sad
because all the other people who could
benefit from it they either don't know about
it or they can't pay even fifty bucks a
session
and that gets dick is really frustrating so
what's that ya freelancer people can think
you're cheaper expensive the same time
because of the customers true so my
obviously my new take on this is to is to
share this as much as possible lives and
those people who do have money like mr. Jim
who you know gives me 25000 b 1 day people
who have money who want to see Society
progress can opt in to support me doing that
thing and I had to tell you I kind of wish I
had gone this
wish I had gone this route earlier because I
mean I don't know that it's for everybody
but they're still going to be a need for you
to help people one-on-one no matter what
this live mentoring is not going to do it
for that one or two people out there who are
you know alone and trying to learn and they
come here to try to get a community to
support them but they even need more support
they need someone to meet with them when I
want and to get them you know really to
where they need to be
and it's unfortunate because those people I
don't know what options they have right now
this early but covid
I did the online thing to write I don't know
if you saw that I did online mentoring
through Discord one-on-one for a full year
and that works fine and works fine
but yeah
right
third of my class wow
icons icons on
tutoring but setting no bueno no bueno yeah
I think
I don't know what is a sort of meta lessons
it's come out of this is is that the problem
isn't that people don't have the skills or
don't want the skills is why I keep coming
back to this is all of that stuff I think
and it you are current educational system
all of it is all a symptom of a deeper
disease regarding learning and education
that Sir Ken Robinson talks about Impala
fairy talked about before it's this idea
that you have to have we need permission to
learn we need I think
and I know this is one of those stories so
there is a there's a very hippy family also
say that if there was a good friends of ours
the bike everywhere though cuz I got two
people herbicide do you get in there thank
you though and I told her before about
telling again he came into he came into my
space the teenager that teenager very
successful a beautiful kid he came in and he
looked around at the screens and everything
and all the all the learning it was going on
his life and he looked kind of he didn't
look angry or anything he just look like he
was unimpressed and I had to get his
thoughts on this I was like how's it going
what's up like things out of his mouth
people pay for this and it was so shocking
human unschooled his whole life and the guy
was like off-the-chart intelligent and he
had all these different skills you would
never know if I looking at but he had
constantly had his creativity and his
Independent Learning in Courage from the day
he was a baby he had never been in any kind
of oppressive learning environment where sit
down there and shut up talk when you're talk
to you and you know that kind of thing he'd
never had been encouraged from the very
first day to play in the sandbox to explore
and everything in in he literally look like
he just landed on Mars is like do they
resist really work for people to they really
responded it's cuz I don't get it why would
anybody pay money for this and I tell that
story because that is somebody who hasn't
been subjected to the virus that is
oppressive education that the systems
because he he hadn't he never known it
and if we can get everybody I know it's a
pipe dream but if we if we can get more
people to realize that
Nate you don't intend to wake up whoever
that that Lerner is inside of them I think I
think we could spend your energy doing that
and it's it sounds really I don't know it
sounds like life coaching you know but I
truly I think that's the problem
I think that's the problem and I think
that's related to what they want teacher
once said the teacher said hey if you want
to help and learn a help improve their
family situation was not just a family
situation it's also helping the kids
confidence and helping them want to learn
and helping them ReDiscover their their
Natural Curiosity and all the things that
they may have lost
yeah I know
probably came from the parents and stealing
that sense of curiosity the kids I don't
know I don't know I like to this day as I
said if I would ever actually go get a PhD
in education that's what I would say I would
want to study human psychology and learning
because I mean that was one case I was one
data point right what it what about I mean
can we could be argued that the parents
injected him they forced him to be created
right was he that way naturally was it a
learned behavior are people in a like like
the Sir Ken Robinson says are they naturally
creative or or are some people just
naturally Duds you don't really give a shit
you know what it what's the actual date of
here I think the one thing the science and
just you know random opinion would agree
with his that everyone's different
and we need to cater learning to each
individual that and that's that's virtually
impossible and an institutionalized system
I've had some kind of stake in
30 different people in 6 hours a day
how do you get
does work for her number of of kids
yeah
and it's another one how do you get him to
learn things that Society needs them to
learn that they don't want to learn like
personal finance or algebra
geography for I hate you know I would often
talk with teachers and I'm like yeah I know
I am being very selfish I would I first of
all I would filter everybody out nobody I
didn't teach anybody who didn't want to be
taught and if somebody's interested to Wayne
I would work with them and if it didn't
admit I would say you do there is nothing
wrong with saying you don't want to learn
how to code and I thought I would say a fond
farewell to them and they would go off on
her magical way and if they didn't want to
do it I didn't have to deal with him and
that that is not the case for most Educators
you know you can't
there's some people look not everyone's
going to be passionate about everything but
yet we need people to learn certain things
and that's you can teach passion like yeah
yeah. It says they're so damned if acacian
yeah
right
yeah and that's that's you know might have
another datapoint my my step-son and we just
found out he got his test as positive yes
covid news in the other room is quarantined
right now so bad for the guy but he pretty
much lives in that room anyway
so he has autism and he he's been totally
uncool completely and the level of knowledge
that he has is just overwhelming on so many
topics it's just absolutely mind-boggling
just letting him learn on his own when he
comes to do use too many tries to write a
note though his in his spelling his
handwriting is atrocious in his feelings
really bad and he knows it and we joke about
it I'm not throwing him under the bus he's
breathing kid I really brilliant
sothey say something is very controversial
but does everybody have to learn everything
what if we you know what if we would have
some. Some people my buddy said I am never
learning to type I going to be a doctor I'm
going to have somebody type for me my whole
life
I don't be a sage on the stage and don't get
on the side be a guide on the side like that
again
yeah
different right
yep rent
Escape my mind I'll be like damn you too I'm
glad you said that because it is it's about
learning together to I think
Annie I think one of them pills of my stream
possibly has people watching me fail over
and over again I don't pretend to know
everything obviously I'd like you just point
her to I think we need to go back to
Friendship is a society skip the college vs
and do a printer some the job for free men
of time and then switch around and see which
ones you like or that I work for right now
the company I work around that's exactly
what they do they take people out of college
to let him try a bunch of different areas in
the trade and then they can kind of find
their own way and then they can go deep into
that one area with a with a personalized
Mentor who is in the industry working in it
or somebody who's retired you're all so
you're also talking about the Boy Scout
program and I keep coming back to the front
I'm not particularly fond of some of the
stuff about the Boy Scouts but their model
of Education totally works and it's based on
mentors stepping in and guiding as opposed
to you know that guide on the side kind of
thing I think Alex said and and then having
you know their time free to do the other
their career and then having the person to
the work and come to them and if they have
the experience is really hard to say OK our
society is all of a sudden going to make it
culturally
you know unpalatable to not Mentor someone I
personally believe in a society where
everybody in the society signs on to being a
mentor in some capacity to somebody else at
least one other person out in it or outside
of their home during for at some point in
their life I think that that should be a
societal responsibility and we seem like we
we dumped that responsibility on teachers
hey you're not doing it right meanwhile
they're over here you know but I'm making
money and they just want to be bothered by
it too much education fortunately is just
glorified babysitting and I'm that's not a
slight against teachers that's
and it's it really is it's just a care with
hey let's learn something and I I feel like
that's a disaster actually you wouldn't have
been if you hadn't had mentors yet if you if
you look deep the teachers that impacted you
the most I can name them by name they were
my mentors
I think non-family mentors are essential I
have overwhelming evidence of that from my
own experience you can't learn stuff from
your parents that you have to learn from it.
Everybody knows that a certain age of
teenage development if you have if you have
an influential independent adult in that
person's life it makes all the difference
and yeah you we need to have that you need
to have that the arm's-length separation
from that's not to say that you know
parenting is a bad thing it's just I don't
know why but the psychology of development
and involves moving away from your parents
and and I'm very happy to say that I got to
be that that adult for a lot of people and
one really good picture yeah
yeah could you I mean if you were to
describe the qualities of that teacher
though it's almost like they were a mentor
and they just happen to be a teacher
yeah
resonated with me so yeah yeah absolutely
I yeah I have had the same experience I
talked about a lot when I do the voice thing
but yeah I'm packed I had several
experiences with that growing up and that's
what overwhelmingly influence me to to say I
want to do that if I'm going to leave this
earth
you know one of the things I mean I failed
at many things but one of the things I want
to say that I did is I am I at least help
somebody else along their pride their path
of learning is finding their way because God
knows we need it you know I mean we all need
to do is the person that's that help you buy
you know they they might not have been there
for somebody else they probably were but it
was I mean to what extent is that a
personality thing right
can you tell me this mention like yeah
at the end of the day you're not going to be
able to connect with absolutely 100% exactly
I just did not like me
that is just a different in personality type
some people like a Gruff I mean you know
yeah that's exactly it some people want kind
of a militaristic kind of rub you down kind
of Mentor they respond that some people
don't that mean we don't even really need a
debate about what the different method of
mentoring is it's it's a personal thing,
certainly there was like you know certain
laws of you know neurology like in a
reputation up to remember things like that
but but and and dopamine foremost learning
and as as more than cortisol which means you
probably shouldn't be you know nothing of
people all the time but I think yeah it's
essentially a personality thing and
that's that that's another reason that I
think that that this rehearsal system
doesn't do as well as because everybody's
got that story about they're really great
teacher and they're really horrible teacher
and somebody else may have the same story
and reverse it just depends on how they
respond to certain people I suppose there's
certain things people can do that everybody
universally hates like throwing rulers that
you like mrs. Walling I'm looking at you my
kindergarten teacher oh my God
that was a long time ago that was a long
time ago so I don't even think she's alive
that poor woman I mean she wore a back brace
if she was you could have been a John Hughes
movie about her she was just she was just so
bitter and angry and in pain all the time
and she just took it out on her children
that ain't kindergarten I think a lot of
people do
I was being funny about talking about
education I don't want to dwell on the
negative side of it but I think you're right
about one of the drawers of the Shadows
watching you fail
what's wrong what's going on that I having
right after I think that's true do you know
how many times I like Delta that affect you
know and I don't know
I think perpetuating the myth that your
teacher knows everything I don't know how
many times I had to fight that people say
you're the teacher you're supposed to know I
don't know how many times I heard that and
shut that shit down
I was like I am just like you I forget
things I have to look things up you need to
get okay with that
okay with that because you're a mean
I also think you're allowed to do that in
the in the public education space are you
I don't know why
100% I mean we're like yeah yeah
yeah and let them do the learning learn as I
learn to be a successful them or whatever
people think experts know all the answers
that they go straight to the correct answers
your people are still working things out and
they feel terrible about it and you see the
Sun for all the time I have people knew
people break into tech on Twitter and I hear
him say hey everybody is it bad that I
searched everything out cuz I can't remember
anything I don't like how the heck did you
even start to think that the rest of us just
have all this knowledge on on recall all the
time cuz we never have and maybe I'm missing
something maybe I'm the one you know what is
this a I think exam suck they should be
different I have to agree that the other day
I told my students that I'm not
intellectually more capable than them I just
know more about the subject matter at this
point in time and care enough to give him
yeah I really don't want students to fear me
because he creates this weird you're
absolutely plus it gives me the freedom to
say I don't know anyone do is right I think
say
I have a memory I have a brain just like you
I forget things this like you and people say
it goes and it goes both ways by the way
you can have somebody say you're supposed to
do that cuz you're a teacher and you can
also have somebody say oh my god there are a
wizard they know everything and they can put
you on a pedestal and that's also bad
because then they then they don't ever think
they think that you know it's some through
some magic you became better than everybody
else and you you need to have some people
realize that at the end of the day it's
about time it's about experience it's about
practice I got here earlier than you that's
the only difference we're learning together
this is why pair programming and pure
learning is so successful in it in the
Enterprise space because that is the natural
way to train somebody and that is
apprenticeship it's just a small scale
apprenticeship
you know I love I love I love I love how I
spend my days looking up at the dock and
looking and like I wonder if somebody like
me could
demonstrating that I'm willing to learn
yeah I think that's the thing I think if you
want it I mean it goes back to
I don't know how true this is but the best
way to teach is to just show your example
you know and there that's not completely
true hypomania mean you've got to got to
organize a little bit more than that right
you have to create a guy to what to learn
but
part of that is showing example that it's
okay to fail and and it's hard it's hard
it's hard because I fail and spectacular way
is every day for everybody to see it's very
it's very uncomfortable but I'm okay with it
actually helped me grow actually I think the
more people that can learn to be okay with
with failure in really silly weird bad ways
add before I think I'm afraid of being
exposed and that's the Imposter syndrome
thing
if you can learn to laugh at yourself which
means
better of your usual yeah
I think you're right I think I will and I'm
going to go back to Nature
you know whatever your position on Evolution
natural selection in science and all that
nature learns through failure
nature try something try something try to
date her is 100% practical nature is not
theoretical nature do something until it
doesn't work and if it doesn't work it dies
out and then if anything that worked remains
that is the nature of of life and and so I I
just I feel like we need to accept that and
let me try something to do with that that's
what I mean all the Statue of Liberty
Machinery stuff is this racket for this
little while
so I know this is really fun topic I am a
time but I cannot talk about this all day I
tend to do do that I think it's a great time
me for Sunday's I don't have any particular
guide on how to do independent Consulting
but as we wrap up the sash I just want to I
just want to say if anybody out there is
considering
mentary on the side for money or not then
it'll go for it and you got a community of
people here than a little help you get
started I have no financial interest in that
I certainly love having your support makes
me feel good but the reason I'm saying this
is because
I think this is the way to fight this I
think we do a Grassroots kind of thing and a
tell Jim Bob is is is one of these people
who's doing it to it we need that we need a
Grassroots movement that is very practical
very you know if you'd own the ground kind
of approach and we need to start encouraging
more people to reach out to others to beat
make themselves available and we need to
encourage more people to share their
failures and I'm going to say it I'm going
to make a call I did there's there's do you
know a few people interested a if you are
inclined not everybody can because of you no
privacy issues and jobs and stuff like that
mentored learning communities and organic
Mentor learning communities for the Wind
Community is really the secret of all this I
mean this anybody for a second he's been
watching me for the last year or two and by
the way Friday was my 2 year anniversary and
I get Bob by the way thank you almost want
to cry Bob thank you so much for pushing me
into streaming
level up faster but I have to say it ltn Bob
and thankfully in the Stream with me right
now was the my step-son and told me this to
my other stepson but Bob said you need to
stream this and when he did I started my
first Dream two years ago on Friday so if
you whether or not you want to stream your
failures or your Joys it doesn't have to be
just about streaming you know I are El
contento gaming everything like that we're
starting to see more and more streamers but
I have noticed I've been watching too much
lately and it's not just me we need more
people to be vulnerable live so that they
can develop communities that will respond to
that not everybody is going to respond to
the grumpy old guy write obviously
yeah but they're there are people who will
respond to two other students who are
learning at the same time and I try to
encourage him I try to raid them so I'm not
saying you have to be a streamer but but but
you know just being out there for people to
just being a part of a community where you
share you're going to get as much out of it
as you're going to give probably and it
don't do it for the money you don't do it
because that's what I mean come on
it's not worth it for that you're going to
have to stop a job and everything but also
it will taint your content I have refused to
do that
I think it's a fantastic but don't be
it's a fantastic but don't be afraid to be
vulnerable I I think that's important. I
feel like we need to do that more sarcastic
but it's a lot of it it hell it is ya a
crazy amount of work just life story is a
lot of work and God knows I have a whole
zettelkasten full of Lessons Learned on this
particular point and all of which I hope to
write down and some more formal way for to
help others do this you want to do it yeah
as I've always said I'm not even joking I
stream for very selfish reasons I am a very
social person I have no friends except my
family that's not true Bob down the street
which we hardly ever see each other but
so this is what I came for that and to I
come here because I'm willing to fail and be
laughed at if it means that I learned
something in the process so I am extremely
selfish in my desires to be a live streamer
you start Life Learning a few months ago.
Project that people are scared to coat
always come into the stream and ask for tips
as not to scare people away and simplify
thinks it's fantastic rated so that's great
I think I'm following you I hope I am if I'm
not I'll follow you yes I am yay so yeah
anybody out there regularly we'll we'll try
to please read young people stranger other
people seem to not let you know we're doing
different things and head to join the call
are you going to the Discord and raise your
hand you want to try it
okay binary
yeah
it's but we can put you can put me in the
background with the with CeCe on now that's
why I did that I wanted to be able to cuz I
have been doing that to people to you know
so you can just watch the words you don't
have to listen to me talk
you too man
Nikki you still want to try this you want to
give us a shot
typical hey Nick yeah if you want to give it
a shot you can
I say your name is going to come in now 7
minute cooldown
oh God what I think we might be done for the
day hey Nick if you if you want to set up a
stage in yours though that's how you do it
that's what I didn't want to see it to you
there's a new channel to let me just talk to
it since it's going to take some minutes so
you just add a new stage and
people are just put people on the stage and
then come in and then you just they raise
their hand and you authorize them
and then they can come in here they can talk
it's pretty cool it takes care of that whole
voice Channel thing you know who they were
posted also notifies everybody that you're
alive when you doing but I'm not about to
let the closest for the day I actually need
to stay on on schedule so I'm going to close
this this video will go up to YouTube as as
an AMA session of some kind I might even
highlighted because we talked about
education so much inside the coffee right
cuz I'll be back Sunday nice and I will be a
hot dog sound like
I'm actually going to go ahead and
know what I'm going to highlight this video
so let me just put a marker in the video
and then I can just leave it on we don't
have to do anything we can leave it on at
want to lose everybody
add marker end of edutalk
the thing here in this world you want to
give it a shot
so do you see decision Junior
you're just going to have a 7 minute time
out
oh you are in Discord this is you nice okay
got you. I thought you were Nick for S Nick
I don't know why it would have a 7 minute
cool-down on that must be I think I don't
know we got really really trolled bad in
Discord like really bad I had to turn off
graphics and all kinds of stuff it was
really horrible it was horrible I don't like
remembering him
it was horrible so what am I going to be
doing I think it might be some connection
yeah
is a diction yeah something like that I
could probably could be that or so
you coming come to the server needs to be
part of the community for some time yet I
think that's what it is I guess probably a
safe thing to Safeway to do that alright so
in the meantime y'all can watch the fishies
and listen to music so I'ma come back in
about 6 minutes
and will we we we can talk some more I don't
know what I'll do if it's still taking guess
I guess I'm just going to Gastonia it's time
today I don't mind doing it all day actually
but I kind of want to do some of the stuff I
were talking so I'll see you in a bit
oh I'm late I'm in coffee Aya coffee coming
what should we change the topic to
oh we have people at their hands raised hey
Nick how's it going Nick
you might have to turn your mute thing off
play to speak did you get it
I think you have to like click on the invite
yeah make sure you hit except apparently it
says invite to speak
I probably stepped away to take a break
there he is how are you
do I need to change my volume because
everybody else here and finds kind of low on
my end
let me see if I can turn you up
the low for you yeah I noticed I noticed it
here I can turn you up I'm going to turn you
up now to say something
I've got you cranked up to 200%
how about there's that was good oh my God
that's perfect here in the yellow yay
that's the Nick I know I can hear him you
like one of the guys I know by voice because
I've watched you
so
well that's always fun musics a bit loud all
right I heard it turn music down
how's that music is down is this something
new
so here's ears Mister Nick Nick when does
data science one of our other favorite tech
streamers
are they doesn't know now can you make sure
you go follow an X1 underscored 80s CID
Desai
I have a question about dating sites
actually for you are you have you been
reading I read something to the data science
is fading out
and that machine learning was going to take
over and I was going to do was going to get
rid of the need for data science and I
wonder what you thought of that
doesn't seem true to me on the surface but
their logic is something along the lines of
analyzing existing data is going to be less
important than our statistics is something
that's going to be less important than
watching gobs of data and making models or
something
yeah
exactly now
so yeah
yeah
yeah or Flash was going to kill HTML or
something like that you
I feel like it's still in that like new
still yeah
5 years of
yeah I noticed that so anybody just asking
so that's actually read what Wikipedia says
about data science is an interdisciplinary
field they just a scientific methods
processing algorithms and systems to extract
knowledge and insight from noisy structured
and unstructured data that sounds like
somebody he was mentioning that you've done
a lot of sports data analysis right just for
fun and thing
yeah
Pro Bowl ratings
NFL really did. Wow
wow
didn't they ask you to do something that
trick wow
so is so is dating site so I'm I'm being
very selfish I'm asking all the questions
I've been wanting to ask you so
so in a nutshell how would you describe the
difference between data science and machine
learning
personally if she learning would be like
one of the basic data science
predictability and that's not necessary
would it be safe to only be safe to say if
you had like a big circle that is data
science that machine learning is like a
circle within it and then you have like you
know like our analysis that statistical
models and other things like that would be
within the larger thing and you probably
have people specialize in machine learning
within the larger data science field is that
computer science
okay so so you could get away with not
learning are and still call yourself a data
scientist if all you knew how to use his
pytorch or something you know I know I work
with him
self
but they don't know our enemy and they
barely know how to go by there and you know
but they they know their pie towards you
know they know their cancer for they know
their favorite Machinery Library basically
yeah when I left I use that too much I want
your funny yeah it's okay to do that but I
mean even if you had of a broader exposure I
guess I guess what I'm asking is I'm helping
people make a decision you want to go into
the career what is the one thing they can
learn I truly believe that the world is
headed toward bus programming and more
machine learning models I I don't have any
solid basis of that other than just got
feeling watching video Keynotes but but I
feel like that's where we're going so I
I'm kind of intrigued about how we get
people going on Machinery career
specifically
and I guess that that would start with
learning python or
also work a lot to develop a lot of heat
I got something my opinion like
real Gateway
oh really wait wait wait did you say did you
say escarole
if you think it's so okay that's actually a
related question I've been so for a long
time this is a long question actually have
to set it up for a long time I've been
teaching a data class and my day to class is
nothing like what you probably expect we
would start based on practical stuff I
learned doing a Nike with lots of people who
had data in all different types of reforms I
was kind of Consultants within the company
to try to get people onto the web and that
men having them figure out with their domain
model was and what their data is models were
in figuring it out and they always had data
and different formats right they had this
CSV that this spreadsheet that they would
sit around each other update their sales
numbers they had this they had data and all
different places in forms in meth and
and so when we did the day to class we said
okay it's not just about learning ask you
also. Learn about machine learning it's like
we need to just talk about data in general
had to reorganize it how do we capture it
had a way to manipulate it how do we get
data how do we and to me that's that's kind
of the true definition of data Sciences
understanding how to deal with data.
Yeah and is the marketing that people that
did something to him
we're leaving around 1:20 going over towards
supernovas his Machinery no that's why I
think that might be my favorite Ringling
yeah
I told you all this boils down to simple
questions like where do we teach somebody
SQL and when do we teach him Jason itcs on
his part of development usually because it's
already a data structure that maps to type
so it helps people understand types of
python or JavaScript but have a precursor to
that so it kind of goes with coating but
like where do you put that right
lot of more modern statistics programs will
likely be completely changed
it looks like they're being taught in our at
this point
yeah
are they learning sap really God I wish
pyramid
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it is 2
a second I thought you were you say ASAP and
we have a we have a person here accomac Road
works there he's talked about a lot so but I
know that that's a different thing it's kind
of Enterprise management software if I
remember right
yeahyeah I think you're right in
learning sequel
yeah
Styx elective course
six people they're learning it after they
learned. But for Pomp's Tire Company hearing
people yeah it kind of goes with everything
right that's the problem it's like the first
one they don't teach it anywhere and you
kind of need to know what I meant I printed
out the entire post this manual no kidding I
had like you know like a foot of books
because I needed to build a day tomorrow
when you're teaching ask you will you can't
really teach SQL without to some degree
teaching data modeling please have to learn
to think about the organization of your data
before you can normalize it if you're going
to normalize it and you know what even a
relation means but
but I feel like I said I was a part of the
bigger conversation about data in general
but I actually don't know where it fits so
I've actually been trying to put in my
calendar here and sometime when I guy turn
to Nick and I say go watch next course on
data science because I'm just going to talk
about I don't want to do something we need
to talk about what we're going to talk about
it here but yeah I can't get away with not
talk to you about Jason and yeah I'm also
I'm well bottom line do they do you have to
know as you will to consider yourself boost
did you know into an infrastructure career
does not require it there's no doubt that
doesn't require none of the stuff that I
have here necessarily requires is Jana think
that's kind of a problem requires the animal
and Jason and and and Jesse has to be in
that kind of thing
but yeah so I don't quite know where to put
it I was probably means I won't be putting
it anywhere and and that's a talk about data
modeling is an essential part of creating
any application you know cuz you can't
create a structure without knowing what the
things are in your system right so
I mean do you hear the terms the main
modeling a lot
I mean is that something that gets thrown
around the term domain modeling yeah
no okay well let me just repeat for the
others out here is so date domain modeling
is the practice of coming up with the things
of Your World of your application it's
essential part of applications development
because if you don't know what that things
are you don't know what the structures for
the things are going to look like and if
you're going to go pee you kind of person
you what the objects are going to be the
classes Etc and all of that ultimately lands
in the database as well which what do you
name the column we have student we have
named we have you know address I kind of
think so domain modeling is is sitting down
with a business analyst in our systems
analyst to just saying what are all the
things and just kind of extracting out of
the person all of the words all the the main
language of whatever it is you do whether
it's culture or whatever and then you create
those terms in those terms have unique and
specific meaning to you and you are to me so
the word class to you might mean something
completely different than it does to
somebody else maybe you're talking to
somebody who's about
ologist the term class has a different
meaning than an educator they're going to
think the worst class in a completely
different way and two main modeling is
capturing all of those things and and
describing what they are so that you can
then do the next step which is
step which is make applications that use it
and make data models that model of your that
the stuff in your demesne so every saying
there is because they probably don't sit at
the database they just likely consume it
interesting
what do you think of that Nick that
Bestco
you run a baseball team ohmygod that's cool
that's cool
oh my God
a job that's that's that you're the first
person is that kind of job I've ever heard
of that is amazing
wow
whatever you need
just figuring out like for the deals that
were pulling in and kind of size
requirements in cash for what kind of size
requirements for a particular VM would we be
creating but also looking for a round it on
yum brands KFC and still be asked to do
things that like maybe a data scientist in
start-up would be doing
did they give you it probably give you the I
mean I I I'm getting down there to the brass
tacks here I mean who makes the names for
the columns in the database is somebody else
tell you hey we want a database and it
should have this stuff in it
teacher store no
and a future store is basically that stuff
where you take it to get it into a Ford
we're like
weather
Ashley now that's
updating 44 population ETL title job
two of each
that's cool I'll actually know what tekton
is now I we we are supporting checked on at
work and they've been pushing for you to
have this install and maintain it and I'm
here reading about what if he just tore his
as well hear about it so that's interesting
so that's then yeah I'm really have to learn
about that that's that's like taking the
data to the idea of a datatable and then
making it some into something way more you
have your coat on and the dog is there a
sounds like you want to go for a walk or do
you want me to just say how cute you are cuz
you're very cute
I don't how I go to my boots and get my
boots out and go for a walk
I guess we're going for a walk this is
interesting Nick if you want to stay on and
talk you can I'll leave you alone okay but
I'm going to go for a walk
I let you want to go straight when I get
like radio
yeah there's a chat are you tell me about a
dinosaurs I wish I could let you drive the
screen up everybody I'm going to I'm going
to I'm going to go walk the dogs so I'll
talk to you later
unless you want to chat and stream sup to
you
yeah yes yes yes just just keep talking by
I'll be back in like 15 minutes
in there
turn down for What
enjoyed that class in anyway you have a
strong shot
play music
the word machine learning in
weird side
a lot a lot of that
how to make your own that for Bitcoin mining
block
running joke is like the we wasted Talent on
the fart app
I've done it a different one
Goodfellow
there's a lot of a lot of outstanding
problems aren't there
people in here who are very smart and you
were able to dedicate today
machine learning is
the baseball to Fried Chicken then back to
baseball
the blood flow back into the
Alicia
and everything is perfect like all the
timing
feels like when you're working with potato
slices
Visual and
because I'm also a functional idiot
white light on
a lot of calculus
trust me with a problem
personally I had to take the timer base in
play I'm talking to y'all right now
today
learning from the master and sub
oh that's great
hanging out
me too I'm here too I don't know if you
remember but my doorbell rang like several
minutes ago and that's like
made it back yet I made it back
what have you here on Sunday afternoon
personally I'm a pretty late Jana a lot of
my friends were
view notebooks and Rose people who
early plenty of people you know
good good on y'all
I usually just like Rob
pretty little notebooks are pretty cool
though all things all things being said
I like nope yeah
definitely
oh I was fantastic I thought we had a video
about the posted our dog is freaking out out
in the snow is really fun we we don't get
snow in North Carolina very much so when
they give us a hundred percent chance of
snow weigh compared to Utah or a girlfriend
but makes me want to go skiing
message mrs. Misses you think
what should what should we do some coding I
feel like
and we should get back and do some more and
we've been I don't know if you know but
we've been trying to use ansible to
provision workstation via torture machine
that voice it reminds me of Nick one because
it is Nick one
yeah I know it sounds so much simpler
yeah I don't know how is your Sunday going
everybody Sunday going hopefully you guys
are having a good time today I'm certainly
just low key
all right take care of thanks for holding
this dream up I'm going to take another
visitor here
I'm only code
to Buco who are you on Twitch I need to know
who you are before we stream you
I've had an epiphany anybody invoice until
syrokan recognizer is that you are okay
I figured Russia
you have to click on accept sell it.
Professor
tabuk osso buco
yeah we're just I'm just going to leave me
just go to open it wants to join.
Give the scores are Discord chat and you
click on the stage in there and come on in
and raise your hands
I is my sister sounds is my sound too low
for you
if you want to talk you let me know let's
figure out some coding to do Shelly
yeah hello I heard you I'm at the train you
up though
somebody say something I think they did Adam
table into an octoprint server low
I feel like I want to do something fun
and random why should we do if we do
something fun or random or should we go
watch it we should take a break and play Old
The Witcher this afternoon since it is
a beautiful day I actually am I going to be
streaming for a little while more
so we are not interested
I've been I've been working. What is your
sleep schedule what are you guys do
I'm going to try to do the 5:30 to 8 again
and then when it's so I've got about an hour
left I'm going to play some Witcher so I
realize only now that the stream is largely
a key macro is here welcome key macro
so we were actually just talking about and I
miss heard somebody say SASS and I thought I
said sap and they were we were talking about
what sap is
just as a piece of kind of thing where if it
came back and wants to talk about it's the
kind of thing where there's a lots and lots
of Enterprise working it and nobody knows
what it is
it's a very specific thing
go look up CSS battles use it for web
students I've heard that's pretty fun to is
that the one with the zombies and stuff I've
seen it yet that's a pretty fun pretty fun
to olds well
what's on Twitter I was just being
completely random
is this a tweet that somebody said we should
look at I went to land it to become a ux
designer I went through another coding
bootcamp to become a software engineer was
taught Java and got a job at Chase
this is what ice ice this is what I said I
owe even though the job I have now has
nothing to do with Mom. I haven't got I
haven't got my first check she's
that's pretty scary
I won't be using any knowledge or training
that I received your mind at that job my
title isn't North anything to do with user
experience design but because I make just
over 50k a year guess what they got some of
it anyway
oh my god really this is almost $900 a month
that won't be going towards bills or
anything for my kids
well I've never heard that about Landa
before
that's I'm really that's very controversial
but let's talk about it
they tried to do their own service match
their headquarters for 30k r380 km from you
oh my God
is a recreate things to CSS maybe I don't
know that when I look at him
whoever post this I'm really glad you sent
me this
I really am glad yeah
about
this is not cool
this is not cool I don't I don't want to
throw any particular company or the bus but
anybody doing this deserves it
they went to Landon school to become a user
experience designer I would say you know she
webjob my God
this is what this is what it says I owe you
have the job I have now has nothing to do
with Landa
how can they make that model work your
wonderful that
you know you know it don't let's talk about
that
I'm using my pee love for him sorry it is so
so what do you think
is acceptable there I mean
I know
this is super and she I am a coffee
so when do you think
I mean this is this is quite an eye-opener
for me what's my Twitter
Arne ekstrom so
going to listen think I saw you in a listen
thing I have to do is waiting to be invited
key macro
yeah if you raise your hand it's at the
bottom is the thing at the bottom says hi
raise your hand if you raise your hand then
I can bring you on the stage just so you
know for the future if you want to try it I
mean if it were only that I have I don't
know what I'm doing either
Trump
my wife made brownies my garden I'm never
going to get skinny
yeah sure I see you in the in the lobby now
if you find the thing where it says raise
your hand and then I can click on your
request and then that'll send you an invite
in you can say except
if you want to try it no requirements I just
just just just available to you if you want
to try
God am I kind ofGod damn I kinda want to
talk about this this is quite a slap in my
reality check face
I used to say I'll walk was awesome sauce in
the dog is so happy she's like passed out
he's like passed out now cuz she was like
running around she grabbed a huge Branch
from a tree and was running around a whole
tree branch
so funny
hey there is Q I want in but I sent you an
invite you should get an accept notification
Q
I'm going to check your sound levels
I suppose I should take you guys out on a
walk it's probably like four inches of snow
out here he was in the house I see that
you're muted
self meeting I didn't meet you on the
monitor here there we go
it's totally working in your sound levels
are perfect
hi and do you know how to turn your Twitch
off they tell you to do that I guess so that
doesn't Echo
yeah something like that
yeah not great I did want to show you
something really quick I was showing people
this yesterday we just got this to work and
I I just made a video of you posting today
about this this is live captioning with this
did you have that working already
yeah I mean it I just I'm like so excited
I've been telling everybody particular other
streamers and people like you how are y'all
doing
yeah exactly cut can I ask you I can point
blank question what is sap
I know it's
crazy
most things that we buy or use or whatever
nsm88 they cater primarily to Enterprise
that's probably why people might not know
about it because
understand how somebody would you want
something or if you can control my
management system production system
yeah and that's a big deal so they're there
when it when somebody buys sap it's usually
an Enterprise and they're usually paying
millions of dollars were right out of the
gate. They I mean it's like a big deal I
think isn't it
Sterling
realize is a life outside
I love that you say it that way because
I mean you know it's it's it's one brand one
taste of what it likes to actually have a
job in Enterprise I don't think a lot of
beginners fully comprehend how easy it is to
fall
to fall into a world like sap and to lose
your sense of external reality that you once
had because you were exposed to so many
other things so you come to learn that hey
everybody is not running Arch and you've
ever whatever you know what I mean I mean if
you would just wear to judge the IT world
based on YouTube videos of twitching Reddit
you would be getting a very warped view of
how work is actually happening all over the
world
first commercial sap software products back
into it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
absolutely
yeah I had a I had an executive tell me
straight up while I was running skill s said
why are you not teaching everybody ASAP
that's like beginner level jobs in the end
of six figures easily and you know it's
people don't come out of college going I
want to be in sap engineer let you know they
don't even know it exists and I'm using this
as an example not picking on sap by any
means I just know that you work there and I
mean you mention that and I like the talking
about some of the proprietary elements of
this is looking for a free and open source
here they said they wouldn't think of it but
but in the other so there's a large and
prosperous
industry that that has nothing to do with
what people may have even heard of and it's
just getting the exposure I think it's what
I'm mentioning
Ensure
he is one of the largest open yeah
yeah yeah it not well
wow
don't know what what what what when you say
software engineer are you are you spending
most of your time in the in the sap the
proprietary language or how much time do you
spend in other languages that mean what's up
with the Clips in the equation imagine lots
of java and that's that's pretty standard
for Enterprise so if that's what we
yeah
oh yeah yeah yes
list two rights
yeah
yeah yeah
well you're at you're in that you're kind of
the backbone of supply chain so there could
be all kinds of integration to do it some
point I would think
that's how I went without getting in trouble
though I have to ask him How likely is a
consumed product likely to influence her
stay the same I I've I've real then i b m s
you know you know consume and Destroy
company you know that they're do they tend
to actually apply the Innovations of the
company that they buy being the size of
company that they are
and in terms of the acquisition yeah they
did everybody leave within the first year
after they are you no contractual obligation
to ends and they pursue other interests and
they leave the you know that the guts of the
company that got acquired behind which is so
yeah
yes that's in us that's fair to say about
IBM to I'm free please don't that's my
personal opinion about how stuff goes down
at least the stuff I witnessed it when you
have a company the size of sap there's going
to be that kind of transformation happening
a lot that's going to be with stuff coming
in and going out I'm not just saying this
yeah yeah well that's
yeah yeah
yeah I left anybody listen to me think that
this is like some clandestine marketing Ploy
it's not I just happen to have no cute
Twitter and a new that they were getting
sleepy and I wanted to represent an
Enterprise in our conversation a little bit
I think it's important we do that because I
think there's an under-represented silly but
the Enterprise applications and Enterprise
internal organizations are under-represented
in the mainstream and I think that they need
to be
anybody inside of a big company write in
yeah that's not a couple of summary points
that that are important takeaways that when
you work for a big company your your view of
reality changes somewhat mostly because
you're exposed to the Bad Company's
ecosystem in an environment and networking
people alright I get a sense that that's
changing like I know that you are very good
at connecting with others outside of the
company but I do wonder how would sap view
first of all I mean I know you don't speak
to the company but it may be in your
personal opinion how do you think a company
like this is is viewing the new sort of
remote thing in the potential for you know
co-working off-site and those kind of more
modern work approaches
oh well
anyone in Poland wow
yeah and then you have to do with your
different time schedule which is always fun
to write all the conference calls in like
with the Australians in like you know 2 a.m.
or something
supported so much weed and feed
well you were talking about you can I don't
think this is doxing anything to say that
you had mentioned Frankford at one point
what's your attendance like at that given
the time you guys have been around you've
been doing converses for a while holy cow
yeah
so I guess conferences are would be an
essential part of developer advocacy I mean
that's you're connecting with Developers
yeah it is huge hello I've yet to find an
sap meet up in my travels I mean they
generally I mean I have no time when I
explicitly for that I mean I'm thinking
things like meetup.com places like that
where you could find like a Linux Meetup
it very easily be yeah that's that's that's
what's so fun about it is I think the
takeaway here is there are other ways we
talked about getting jobs we talked about
getting a where of what jobs are out there
and you know people say I know I sent my
resume to this this company and they didn't
answer me when people agree that's not the
best way to go about the job search was a
critical component of job searching is
knowing where the people who do the work
hang out and there and meet ups and there
occasionally on our livestream there but
they they tend to go to conferences to and
you can go to conferences for free sometimes
I don't know that you have one that's free
but sometimes there are General career
conference is out there that you can just go
in and look over at Howard much that is but
you can bounce around and ask people
questions been so if you wanted to
understand the inner workings of sap and
enterprising even knew about it because
maybe your uncle work there or something
then going to a conference or something like
this would would be one way to get a real
good handle on it it would be time well
spent in terms of like the siding is that
the kind of thing you want to dive into
yeah
yeah it might be because
yeah you do and that's honestly that's one
of the reasons that I'm talking to you right
now because I I feel like I said it before I
just feel like the different Enterprise
environments in and working things all that
stuff for under representative that to those
who are seeking employment about that that's
actually good question. Professor has a
question about any else I remember is
signing like the India love all Indy else
would I be on a little late on your dreams
and everything they never came after me for
anything in particular but they certainly
could have they had the legal thing to do
that I remember them getting me and Dallas
to do training and then saying hey here's
some papers you have to sign to get paid
then they didn't really have a choice do you
remember any sort of ndl process with sap
and in general how how do you view the Indio
thing from an Enterprise Enterprises are
more likely to stick in India in front of
you and my opinion
I think that's what I'm talkin about maybe I
misunderstood an undisclosed
okay so
however that you only use a few and far
between and he might soon so for example the
program seeking men.
Music influences your recipe
I do know that yeah
pretty standard thing
yeah yeah I was once it was a startup and
they were just really scared of having their
ideas ideas lost and they wanted to show me
their ideas as an architect and and I'm kind
of given feedback on it and when they gave
it to me I was like you know I chose not to
sign it but they just wanted they literally
just wanted to present it to me and get my
free feedback and I chose not to actually
walked out of that presentation because I
when they when they showed me the Indy a
non-compete is different than you do you
have for sure you're not going to say
anything about what you're about to see and
am basically they can sue you if you do and
especially if you start a job doing that and
I chose this is to the beginners out there I
chose not to look at it because it wasn't
worth it in that particular case may be I
mean if you're looking for a full-time
employer job that's a different issue maybe
I would be more willing to do that but in
this case I just wanted me to sign one just
to see what they pretend
we're going to show me I had no idea where
they're going to show me and they could have
I could have signed it and it kind of showed
me what I am already planning and I could
have given him put on that and said hey this
is an amazing idea I'm actually already
doing that must collaborate or something but
I feel like that was to be greater risk
because what if they did show me something I
was already working on ahead and have any
other contractual benefit from my
association with them and I chose not to. I
don't want to make this negative but I just
do want to make people aware of it I mean 6.
Professor asked a question and be aware of
what you sign out there legally especially
the software engineer
yeah because you can actually look at
software and be tainted just by looking at
it I don't I don't want to scare people but
in this in a hardcore software engineering
world if you there certain projects where if
you participate in a proprietary project you
are not going to be able to participate in a
similar proprietary projects elsewhere yeah
yeah
I'm sorry I just don't I don't I don't I
don't want people to get afraid but anytime
we at the end of topic of Enterprise comes
up I feel like I feel like we do have to
talk a little bit more about you know things
that are more enterprise-e that people may
be may be less likely to to to one of your
need to be aware that I would hate to have a
beginner do that and you sign into a company
and then make themselves on hireable later
you know you don't need to be scared of it I
just think you should be aware of it that's
all
so
do you can go ahead I'm done I'm just I'm
just like everybody else
yeah
what is a great that's a great that we
should just say that again you open your
open your mind I guess. There are two two
other possibilities besides I mean okay so I
got to ask a question from the community
here. You don't have to raise your hand if
you don't want to how many of you had heard
about sap before today
and if you want to raise her hand or put
something in the chat just for fun let me
know if you I just kind of get a sense of it
if you can put me or something if you don't
want to answer except that's fine my you can
put not me if you want to recipe for
sometime okay I need a price so yeah we had
a great guy at Great never knew plenty of my
own emotions I don't I don't understand why
this is very interesting that he says that
the box says it's a German I've heard of it
of course
is it goes to that hands down never there
for 3 years interesting name for me heard of
it know what it is useless to be for
expenses the previous job in university is
so I think it's 8 I mean it's very you know
anecdotal but you know this this is a good
example of a career path this is this is sap
is not Cobalt you know you might you might
associate talking about an old Enterprise
technology as being boring and not
Innovative and stuff there's actually a lot
of I think I think you probably confirm
miscue that there's still a lot of
innovation happening within the sap
proprietary ecosystem
I absolutely agree I I I can't agree if it's
if he had HQ at 7 to get rid of one of her I
would have her exactly the empty and that's
that's what I'm trying to tell you that I
don't even need to ask everybody knows what
the Fang companies are you at now I'm going
to get them going to get a little mean here
okay I'm going to beat up on a on a company
so
I'm going to say something to be very
controversial what's the else is new right
but I got you here and he was very she's
pulling me off the edge all the time which I
really appreciate by the way it's so a
company like Netflix I'm going to pick on
Netflix okay we all love Netflix we love
what they do they provide a really important
service for Humanity art is a part of it
they do films and they they they definitely
benefit Humanity okay but sap has been
benefiting Humanity in very direct if not
more direct ways then Netflix ever has and
so and yet nobody knows about it that's why
I'm trying to make a point here at the point
is this there are companies out there that
you might find initially boring because
they're not being featured on YouTube or
twitch or something like that that have
tremendous value that have tremendous
opportunity that will
this opportunity that will challenge you
that may or may not be proprietary and that
you just don't know about so the only thing
I'm asking for it since he was kind of
randomly agreed to join us here the only
thing I'm asking the community to do is open
your eyes and your scope and look outside of
thing look at many many other things that
are out there and you'll be surprised what
you'll find I was I'm working for a very
unsexy company right now I can't tell you
please don't talk to me I cannot tell you
the company you would definitely know it the
Koch brothers benefits humidity in the
toilet paper yeah that's kind of it I guess
I don't know business-to-business has at
least half the world business is not
consumer focus is much less visible exactly
I mean we could probably make a series just
bringing in a quote-unquote unsexy
Enterprise Technologies bring an open-source
and otherwise and and give him a us an
opportunity to
heard and and say look this is it we're not
just trying to sexy up you know to put
lipstick on the donkey here this is there's
actually true opportunity here and I'm going
to repeat again the company that I work for
right now the it within the company that I
work now makes Google look like a
kindergartener but you would never ever know
it because they don't publish it okay that's
all that's less rent less rent more
welcoming environment again I just before I
get a chance to see if so again Q I'm really
grateful for your being here just going to
randomly coming on in the comments
what is sap we kind of cover that you can go
do you want to review a you can go review
the water you can go back and go to this if
your company again I just want to say it
again I just was not pre-arranged kiwi just
been a longtime fan and sponsor of the of
the stream and he happened to be here he is
a developer advocate for sap so his job is
getting people to like it which is what I
want to ask him to talk about it so I'm
really glad we had him let's see why don't
they advertise their Tech makes recruiting
easier that's a good question
if you're still there it would you be able
to answer that one why don't why doesn't sap
advertise well that's what your job is I
guess but
okay
right
what platforms is
ocean pole between invent anything
yeah
yeah when is ybm doesn't either I mean IBM
got me to leave a job at Nike by doing a
campaign called I know if anybody remembers
this in 2000 or early 90 late 1999 they did
a campaign called peace love and Linux
they're going to remember this peace love
and Linux they did it they didn't active
campaign ad by the way that Google question
I absolutely don't know and you're totally
right I have no way of knowing if Google s
better than the SEK I work at right now
that's complete conjecture on my part you
got me on that one so this is this is this
is the this is what they did peace love and
money and there it is right there just came
out in the 90s 2000 1 ish and they
they inundated the market with this people
where we're putting this guerrilla marketing
it they put it everywhere they can they
created a New Lenox
division within the company and they I they
must have spent thousands of dollars
advocating for Lennox at IBM and saying hey
IBM's cool and I will apply this campaign
got me to look at the company is the
recruiter actually sent me you know that
friend of mine sick to recruit around me
after they had left but it was this campaign
that they had done that until this day I
still love it I still love the campaign I
like want this t-shirt Big Time Rush
probably get it but it's a campaign by IBM
you think I've I've been made a good move
there they pay to get her Bish let's see
what is Salesforce the source is another big
company I don't think they do more about
they do more
I don't do not supply chain ish kind of
things they do offer a bunch of products to
to the Enterprise right you can probably
answer that better than me
what company owns your a relationship yeah
yeah it does seem like I told that there was
more moron communication sells I think
yep take care
yeah I think I think if you ever want to
just chat and Sundays this is day so I'm
going to be closing up here shop here in
like an hour or so but thank you for jumping
something by
and let me know how it goes alright so yeah
this is this is how they got me
I mean who would enjoy the company that
activated this campaign you know it's more
CRM over there yeah I really appreciate you
coming on like that that that that's our
first time doing a staged event on Discord
very articulate and very well-mannered
come like me I'm a little I mean I respect
so don't drink and Route. Even funny anymore
peace-loving the thing is funny as that IBM
started the Peace Love and let his campaign
in the people from Lenox don't even know
it's IBM anymore
City Pub more beer
Bosch love love not found happiness not
found these not found killed bash you just
specify whom to kill
infraction is ring to recreate the things
all the time right now
I got power oh God are you guys fighting
about stuff again
e-service got your memory servers everything
was eiv I made this huge campaign and they
put me in front of everything and and and
knows about the time Apple put I in front of
everything is pretty good in initial letter
in front of something and then making a cool
e server Z this E-Business Easter and apples
like iPhone iPod I this is like a trend
I want this shirt I really want this shirt I
won't lie E-Trade yeah you remember is
everything was em2000 peace love and Lennox
I literally Joy 9 p.m. in January 2000 and I
attributed to this campaign will try to be a
fucking lie by the way
hey huge lie it was a lie they had they had
been one tiny little pocket division doing
experimental stuff with Lennox that wasn't
allowed to do anything by legal at all and
if you thousand and you couldn't do it you
could barely use Linux without getting in
trouble on your desktop that they didn't
even allow Linux on the desktop until
probably 2005 and I was actually part of the
wasn't part of the team but I was only part
of the internal Community pushing for not
getting fired for using Linux on your on
your on your desktop computers
and it eventually came around a standard
image by the way to the day throughout
Microsoft
did they threw out Microsoft Office and they
adopted open office so I'm Ian has done a
lot of stuff did they put a lot of money
into this
so Ellsberg if
hey how's it going welcome and why the
symbol for a Linux is a penguin I don't know
why either I don't know where that came from
I think it's
I honestly don't know Ivy Mo yes I actually
have that somewhere
I have that somewhere yeah what did where
did I put that
yeah I know it was a t-shirt I have a t I
have this on a t-shirt somewhere the Charlie
Chaplin as yes
I think this is the best Logan they ever did
they've done a lot of like really weird ass
logos but this is my favorite favorite
version of the logo
yeah I like it I like it alot
give me a calendar the next days energy like
an iPhone nice
yes I do remember them obviously with great
affection when the things I like the idea of
it is a thing about working for a big
Enterprise is every year you got to send
three thinks Awards to people so you can
send a thank support and then everybody
would go in there and they could buy some
swag off of the IBM's swag site
and you can have it delivered so every every
Christmas or so we will get like two or
three things you get like IBM lawn chairs
and if you could you could you could like
order your own swag you know depending on
where are you in there like better swag and
the good stuff we get sold out this is such
a big company you could go get it if you
order stuff
yes and I've been pissed too and future that
the cast of mash oh God
yes I do remember that I've been had a
pretty big advertising it's pretty sad that
they didn't end up dominating the PC market
they really could have they just they just
didn't get it there's so many parts of the
city just really don't understand all that's
very nice sexy thank you for that
that's very that's very kind thank you for
that
I'm part-time at Amazon for the health
benefits yeah
yeah and I probably would do the same thing
I mean I'm working for a wonderful company
right now
that I that I really enjoy and I don't
intend to leave anytime soon till I it's all
I gets my my karate skills down and stuff
and then we'll we'll see where it goes don't
be afraid to change companies to people even
if a company is treating you well sometimes
you can't we send the thing you know when we
were selling real estate my my wife and I my
ex-wife and I we we made a most of our money
by fixing houses up and then flipping them
in moving someplace else and selling it for
a lot more money and we would do that we
start with a very small house we started
with a house that was seventy thousand or so
and it was a total dump it was a bit share
to wall with another house we fixed it up
and then we sold it we sold it for like
30-40 Grand Prophet support for the wrong
normal-ish Enterprise software and no one
with double heads are intending any here's
an example
oh God I'm a little afraid
I'm a little afraid there's DJ nice Adidas
awesome
DJ Adams what a nice name are you guys are
just a developer Advocate steam so we do we
should bookmark this one
I'm going to look like that one I like the
we have contact with the developer Advocates
because we are a very open community and I
want to make contact with the people who you
can talk to about what is it like working
here what is it like developing for us if he
was it like developing for sale Sports what
is it like the whole thing for Netflix you
know there's enough representation of that
online right now and twitch at least it says
I don't really need to provide that one but
we have had people in Google Play here as
well this is actually one of the goals that
I have for our little Community here is that
we it's actually a fulfillment of what I did
is still stuff we would do this on Friday
nights on Friday nights I we would be like
like fourteen or fifteen of us and our tiny
little cozy place I remember it's snowing
outside one time and I would invite that
like like the CTO Bank of America or the
tech lead from Lowe's or you know a
developer from a local mobile phone company
and they went or a keynote address speaker
for Bitcoin guy big guy guys making the
fridge and he sees people would come and
they would share that we just shoot the shit
with us and we will just eat random crap we
do it with genda and it was just really
informal and inevitably they would always
say I can't believe that y'all want to be
here on a Friday night just talking about
tech with me and they would be impressed
that always make me feel really warm and
fuzzy inside because because they cuz these
people that were attending these Friday
night sessions were actually legitimately
interested in what these professionals did
and most of the stuff that they did was make
him super boring by other people but but
they had an opportunity to talk in positive
terms about their jobs that they loved and
Abednego in The Good The Bad and The Tech
the most tech lead came in the first thing
he asked everybody their he says you're not
using the arrow keys in your venmo are you
that's he actually said that it but I
couldn't we could have had it refers to
better
and so they were able to do it so I say that
story because you know we were thinking
about going into 2020 what is a calendar
look like and these anime Discord sessions
on Sunday I hope to make them more of that
so and we had we had we had Chris Nova on
talking about stuff like that and
professional world and hacking capitalism
that I got from that again and I want to get
my my stuff together will actually be able
to record these I can't record the Discord
right now because I'm blocking all desktop
audio from twitch but at some point that is
the goal that is the goal is for us to be
able to to bring representatives from
different Enterprises including Fang company
on occasion if they can get in here and
defend themselves against me because I'm
kind of hard on them on the phone companies
are probably shouldn't be but I'm harder on
them because I feel like they get a
disproportionate amount of attention
and self there no joke s s a p model it's a
sweatshop yeah it's like it's my job well I
don't know the sap models as if he's model
yeah and that's that's up for people to
decide you know googol has not capsules they
are okay but not worth having and I didn't
even know who yeah
and tentative testify that I don't know so
there we go. So we have Josh DJ and Rick are
all there and over it has to be and tell him
how much you owe me at wow what a name
I told radican recipe Google this looks like
a fun team
and yeah it does it does come down to do I
want to work for an Enterprise or do I want
to work for
myself if I want to work for a small rapid
pay all these companies have what we also
need to do is we need to pull in somebody
who actually works in a Silicon Valley other
sort of start up and can tell you what the
reality of the startup environment is all I
can tell you from my experience working at
teleport as a start-up for fiber and it is a
startup that you know there's there's pluses
and minuses are given take there and you
just have to be aware of that I mean after
that startup yeah I had a lot of stock but I
also had to take unemployment because they
had to let me go because they couldn't pay
salaries cuz they didn't have the money
coming in because everybody thought the
internet was for and I quote a
representative from wordperfect the internet
was for educators and military people and as
soon as I heard that I knew I had to move
I knew I had to move your creative forensic
data start up to compete with my cell right
nice
and I can't further which I have questions
regarding Paradox says I'm about to graduate
and working on applying for jobs due to
physical limitation in normal living live
coding interview is difficult to see this is
why I think the live coding interview is
illegal
I heard you have any advice for dealing with
this in their company's best interfax that
okay I might have a really hard times credit
not going off right now I'm going to start
by by saying some pretty strong things that
I really
but I really believe I believe that live
coding interviews in person are illegal
according to the American Equal Opportunity
Act but they just haven't been tested in
court and I have read so many occurrences of
this there's one I read I also deal with a
lot of people with Autism I've dealt with
people at least one person who had a pretty
severe Natural Pawz and they couldn't they
couldn't come in that person by the way with
somebody that I met at Old Fort and they
came in and I are visiting day I've been
communicating with them online and a very
professional capacity of about CJ scripting
in Pearl Back in the Day for year 4 months
and when that person came in and somebody
open the door and said they said Rob we have
a special visitor for you because I was
community advocate for CGI scripting for our
entire tell for Community with some
thousands of people there and I had this
particular Affinity with this one person is
very astute very good at 4
that person came through the door and they
were practically a quadriplegic they barely
could type and and we had a fantastic
exchange and if you put that person in front
of a whiteboard interview they will not only
be able to get to the interview they would
not be able to perform because of all the
limitations and they can say that they're
going to make a combination for the all they
want but it's illegal some of that some
people's some people's some people's
handicaps will say it's a bad word but is
are not visible
and you put that person you compete if they
put that person in competition against
somebody else who both can physically stand
in front of a white board and I believe it's
not only unethical and illegal and it just
hasn't been tested yet if you want to give
someone a true test of their performance you
have to give them the same circumstances of
that performance in a modified armata way I
think you can find so Socratic the short
answer is be happy you dodged that bullet
and go work someplace else there are so many
in fact Leon learn with me I just said last
week he said that he plays 12 people and of
the people he paced half of them did not
have a live coding interview half of them
more than half those six people of the 12 he
just posted more than 60% 650 60% had no
life putting interview
because what they're hiring you for is not
necessarily going to be buying resortes and
then the justification for these things is
that they're going to want to see how you
think and they want to see how intelligent
you are there is no objective basis for that
there is no objective study of any kind I
would challenge anybody to produce one for
me that says and sticking somebody in front
of a white board and having them talk
through their high pressure requirement to
do a bubble sort of binary sort of solve a
problem if they don't get it right has you
know scientifically peered reviewed
objective data that says that that makes you
a better candidate and they don't give a
shit the companies that do that to you in
that put you through that shit know that
they're doing it and they don't care they
know they can do it cuz I can get away with
it and nobody dusted him on it but I swear
to God there's entire recruiting firms who
have built their entire marketing business
model off of we don't do whiteboard
interviews they specifically identify
companies that do not do those
I can't remember the name of the company
right now it's kind of making me angry
there's a specific recruiting company that
will not work with any of Nate and they have
all their job postings and everything else
and they vet all of the job postings to be
sure that none of them have that shit
because their whole marketing thrust is we
are going to save you from that and they
place people like crazy
so so I certified just that I don't know
anything about Lenox oh wow you got your
is it cool and I can't prove it or I want to
try it once.
As far as Enterprise interview style I don't
I am not so Socratic I know I'm the worst
person to ask that question I have the book
I have the the gills mandatory book that you
have to buy the big ol fucking $40 book that
she makes a new one every year how to pass
the coding interview cracking the coding
interview with no digital version and no
opportunity for every priority because she
just wants the money and she came from
Google and she was our age are hiring for a
sentence you sure you had a crack interview
and now she's making gobs and gobs of money
selling a dead tree only version of the book
to crack the coding interview if you want to
buy into that idiocy fine I don't want
fine I don't want anything to do with it I
have openly blackballed anybody whose teeth
who has any kind of thing like that now on
the contrary if you are like I'm going to
call him out kucoin software where I helped
several people learn enough to get jobs are
they they give you a test you taking him for
a week you do your thing it is any resources
available to you that you can because they
want to test your ability to perform in an
open-world just like you would be able to in
any other way and then they want you to come
back and talk about your solution so you can
you talk about it you have to be able to
until it intelligently talk about it if you
cheated and you copy the whole fucking thing
for somebody else they make them unique for
every case but if they if you were to do
that then probably figure it out but they
also want to see you talk to you how you
solve the problem and they want us to check
your level of excitement about solving the
problem did you just give up did you not do
it that kind of method is way more
productive
and measures performance way better the only
thing that doesn't measure is how you're
going to interact with a team and the only
way anybody can actually measure that is by
giving you a long-winded in an internship or
something like that a lot of people that are
trans a reminder this recently a lot of I
feel a lot was beginners who haven't had
their first job yet so obviously an
internship is a great way to get a job but
Annie's coding test for a great way to get a
job right but I've had people quickly remind
me that those people trying to transition
jobs don't have the luxury of going in for a
week and seeing in a working with a team in
a minute mini internship to see how they
work and get along and I think that would be
the greatest playwright and they and they
barely have time to like do a take-home test
right for a particular job application
and that's assuming you're going to be
interviewed in that way it in the job that I
got right now which is a very nice job very
great job I didn't have to do any of that I
had to an hour interview and I I had come on
with a great recommendation from somebody
was already on the team and that was enough
same way I got the job I didn't have to
justify because they're actually not hiring
they want to see Dem it's about trust so
they just have to prove that you can be
trusted and however you can do that some
have a higher degree than that most of the
jobs that I applied for have not been hard
core software programming engineering jobs
they have been more operational jobs haven't
been software engineering jobs have been
operations with software engineering so it
would be harder to even give me a whiteboard
interview questions they ask me and my last
interview were like describe a time when you
you know screwed something up describe a
time when you are connected a solution when
stuff was messed up describe a tie
I'm in your experience where you know you
learn from a mistake and that those are very
much of operations kind of questions he
wouldn't get those questions in a software
interview so the only units ironic the only
time the only time I've ever done a software
tester job was I applied for prolog
understand I was I was one of the original
programmers in the 90s for years and I was
given a paper Pearl test for this tiny
little company Downtown in Charlotte and I
failed it
I failed it because I hadn't written any
Pruitt's so long it's been so long as the
rain in Perl and they put me in the test and
I was like saying I was like a pencil I was
already in the pearl down pretty sure I felt
that I didn't get the job offer for that
there is kind of ironic because I had
contributed Pearl to the core and I see pad
I had for a while running on thousands of
IBM machines eternally that was highly
complex I'd written cancellation for gpg I
know for sure but but it was said stupid ass
test they gave me to try to write in a to do
a pearl for a specific thing
I know it's quite a bit of talk but I just I
can't get off that topic is one of my
favorite topics because I wish people would
like let go of that you should play with the
chosen code and make sure to do strange
things yes I can make a living not doing
recourse for the national today
evasco really playing dumb with contacts you
wanted me to do this and you defend you to
find you and this music I'm with list of
companies which don't do I Port Franks
Frank thank you so much you deserve your VIP
your VIP today as usual
that's phenomenalthat's phenomenal I'm
adding that so companies
that do not require it's going to be a
buyer's market in other words a job Seekers
Market here because of the resignation and
we think
that's really cool thank you for posting
that
and I'm sorry if I went off to angrily on
that that's a real you understand I have
dealt with autistic people quite a few of
them actually that would be an absolute
brilliant Higher by anybody but they would
freeze up in a wiper interview there's no
way they could get through the web for an
interview and some people would say wrongly
that they couldn't perform because this job
requires you to be able to be in front of a
whiteboard it doesn't fucking required and
you know one thing I am actually really
understands IBM understands how to work with
people on the edge they have been doing this
for far longer than anyting company they
understand what extreme Corky intelligence
in an autistic Spectrum looks like even
before there was a word autism
and one of the things I will totally give
IBM is it they Immokalee was probably I just
if you go back far enough they have been
catering to patent winning Nobel price
people since the beginning they know how to
do it they given first of all the given
their own room and with no fucking shared
cubicle wall and they never have I been is
never done that. Like what the fuck this is
totally stupid at your the science has been
there forever meanwhile Apple decides to do
the thing and all the all the employees like
Revolt to say they want to go in because
they don't want to be in an open floor plan
open floor plans are horrible
like I I no drop out so you can hack the FBI
right yeah absolutely so it's like you know
you know so I don't want anybody to feel
attacked I want the process of whiteboard
interviewing to feel attacked right I think
it's a failed process I don't think it has
any basis in fact and it bothers me because
it's it's directly discriminating against
very capable people and that angers me that
does anger me cuz they're good people and
they deserve a chance and they're not
getting a chance either because they can't
go to the fucking thing like somebody just
reported or if they went to it they would
freeze up so badly they would be having
traumatic time or so the next 10 days about
it
and I just angers me it does so
I see so much of rest so he can keep writing
I didn't you just say I'm actually said some
positive things about Rush yesterday Yeah we
actually reactivated arrest program or the
other name
strangely enough I'm actually warming up to
rest after coding see the last the last
Saturday and the Saturday before that
you want it you want to give me to warm up
for us give me the code in C for a while
I mean there's been so many ft guns and see
and crazy ass things I'm like I might be
able to get over the syntax and rest long
enough to get around this stuff so I may be
coming around for a bigger for my computer
programming and I know that that's what
Frank clubs so that kind of thing so you
know I went to record I went into it very
enthusiastically like to year-and-a-half ago
and I was really frustrated by how hard it
was this easy to spend some more time with
and I like it shouldn't be this hard to
print a fucking helloworld statement but it
actually is that Harden see as well so I
might look the year 2023 might be the year
of Rob eating his hat about rust and I've
said over and over again that if I can I see
a really solid application for it I will
change my position I will it doesn't mean I
like how the community behaves at all but I
have my misgivings about the go Community as
well sometimes or
Seven Oaks Community
how many big companies in the list now the
big companies feel like they have the right
to filter people doing that I would be
surprised I don't think I've been does it
s a c have good getting more chances and
Frank will be the first one to tell you that
I don't have into suffering chops.
. because I can't write Source really fast
and I don't I don't decipher our lives very
quickly it's not it's not in me to do that
I'm very practical person I keep adjusting
until it works adjusting until it works
adjusting a telework swallow test driven
development and that's that doesn't make me
a good programmer and makes me equality
programmer it just doesn't make me fast
because I always have to have tests to make
sure my shit Works Chica and it always has
to be really simple because I'm because I
suck which makes me a wonderful Enterprise
programmer
because if your programming for the
Enterprise you don't want to be clever you
know what to be clever
and you want to have lots of tests and lots
of documentation and lots of our lives and I
need all of that because I can't even do it
without it I have to think through the
problem so much makes me a lot slower but
they result in their being a little bit
better because it's easier to understand
it's usually clear out always spends I'll
just accept that most have a restful chain
and they're already supports a bigger ones I
guess if she was going to be there if Frank
is visiting I do seriously want you to
evaluate in one point since you're into that
space so much is time to go
Tamiya initial evaluation of time to go is
because it didn't support go routines it
wasn't worth it for me but but
yeah it's it's one of those things I've
wanted to come look at it see if it is
reasonable it's it is
it's kind of an edge thing so yeah
we're just kind of floating here I'm going
to get up that quit streaming here pretty
soon and couple minutes
a few minutes I'm going to go ahead and end
at 5
email says anything they want to bring up
here in the end here
anybody else you
which DS you are you talking about what is
DS you
dynamic system updates
a first-year device manager support for
Google has enabled EST on Pixel 3 alright
I've heard that called Evergreen oh
you're talking about something else
decorate sort undecorate never heard of that
that's a python thing yeah
actually no cuz there's other things
languages at decorators decorators I did not
know that apparently he's had it for a while
I think we Jenny was showing me that she was
saying that it had decorated the situation
took me through Modern p h p
texture has decorated for sure yeah
I think decorators are a great way to add
stricter typing two things the decorators
that were using python fabric a pretty
amazing you could use decorators to say what
systems you wanted a particular thing to run
on it's pretty cool if you guys don't know
what a decorator is Dam likes syntactical
sugar that comes in front of a function in
order to give the function additional
parameters it kind of makes the function
into a template that's that's a horrible
get out
as if that's not accurate at all but that is
what it feels like it feels like you're
you're turning your function into kind of a
template it's not but kind of like that
are my controllers
yeah but also only only bigger arm sometimes
I program a control CC I thought they did
some of the lower my about the lower the
lower tiny ones
I really want to see you watch me like
suffer through the ghouligan board stuff
yeah when I do microchip picks up and get
into the assembly I can't wait today that's
going to I don't know where I'm going to do
it though there's no official spot on the
calendar for that
well I don't know if I get out
interesting I ain't got might take off
make a sound like a painful but isn't it
simpler isn't it simpler
I mean I'd end of the day does last memory
registers to memorize
there's only like 10 or something
I don't know anything I don't know what I'm
talking about that stuff I just I know I
want to learn it
I feel like I feel like learning assembly
and see along with all the other knowledge
and learned over the years makes me have
kind of a full-spectrum you know
you can check the box for the Pasture Road
no I don't know if you like Xbox professor I
mean
I don't know I can't allow myself to get
sucked into that again I
I really love security you do it during a
security analyst boost this isn't till next
November
but if you're still around and next November
we need to put together a security analyst
boost and that means I want to give people
the lay of the land will it what careers
there are what are the essentials they'll
need to learn for Securities where the
different angles on security I want to give
reviews of the best security places to go
learn and we only have six weeks to do that
and I want to play at least one level of
hack the box and one level of a fragmented
and all of them over the wire and maybe some
picoctf so during a security analyst boost I
want to talk about pentesting when I like
one of these boots by the way that the idea
of a boost means this is a boost and it was
just giving you a sample of It kind of
boosting your dad on the way and letting you
know so one of the reasons for bringing
people like me ASAP ASAP and so you can know
what's out there and then just for make
Intelligent Decisions about what you want
for to be later that's fine I'm afraid it's
going to be the new Flash out there
are people going to make blogs and web
assembly and nobody can be able to search
them and we're going to go through that
whole shit all over again I'd be a lot worse
and JavaScript only websites webassembly has
the potential to kill the document web
because you're going to have people people
this was Flash they would put their whole
entire website in Flash couldn't read it
couldn't search it
it's going to happen somebody's going to
make some are going to put like a electronic
webassembly or some shit they're going to
put some sort of like really awesome Dynamic
thing and you can have people having
websites that are entirely webassembly
you're going to open up your going to open
up Chrome and it's going to be
that only
that's all it's going to be it's going to be
none of it's going to be searchable it's all
going to be really crazy ass like particle
you know shit and it's going to happen it's
just a matter of time
and I hate people who make their own games
on make websites their their their profile
page will be a game or something and that's
fine as long as you do Progressive
enhancement which means you know that's what
the wa me zapien Progressive enhancement pwa
me to you do your support with technology to
detect and if you detect a webpage hola if
you detect a web page that does not have
support for JavaScript webassembly where has
it disabled you should provide something
that is the cardinal rule of progressive
design if you're not doing it you're doing
web design wrong my opinion if you have an
application that has no business being even
considered a document may be so I don't
think even the cargo or npm Registries
qualify for that sort of thing I think they
can easily have been done as document web
pages but they're not
so so you when you go to Links me to go to
Cargo. IO you get this
I waited to give up this time
oh I went to the wrong page crate that I am
sorry
this is the rest crates website you can't
browse
the crates and let you have JavaScript which
makes sense because they want you to search
through the site
you got hired as a going to your position
hexagonal architecture is the center
designer for God location to seems pretty
popular never heard of it
never heard of it
what isI've already exagonal
architecture you have an ID if I shot
is there any way we can put a Saturday and
it's just like yeah
except a hexagon architecture or ports and
adapters architecture
is an architectural pattern use as hard as I
have a feeling this is something I
understand it's just been renamed would be
the first time so I want to figure out what
it is
everything I called clean seems that if you
have a feeling it's the same thing
let's change our topic show me I am
searching koosu coloring cooler Nang what is
hexa Connell architecture
thanks for bringing this to our attention
I'm not going to able to sleep until I can
answer this question so
done alright topic has been changed
interfaces independency version of Clyde
that's it
n a s a fancy name
why is it a hexagon because hexacon we have
a joke the more hexagons in your logo and
your design the more likely you are to be a
company to be a scared of and not work for
don't put a necessary hexagons in your logos
people it just proves you're just another
Silicon Valley pack
Portland after hours right now I like
Portsmouth a better I guess I'm going to fix
me a call then
if I am wait is that titles
is that create hex hexagonal
slash words end captors architecture
related document
is it Wikipedia on it of course
I'm going to read all about it I can't live
with somebody being played in 14 games
developed on windows are cheap here in
Nashville for my son purses I think it's
only can be
I don't think it will be though did you see
Chrome is shutting down access to the
underlying OS
as it does in the news last week
because because they consider that a fancy
I'm not convinced they're not doing that I
think you might be afraid you might be
joking but I think it is
and open to Baird TX 8600 Mac nice
architectural battery uses a that aims to
create Loosely couple application opponents
I can easily connect to their suffering by
right by means of ports and adapters in
other words good software design
what is the state of fucking name
it's me find this makes components
exchangeable to any level of automation but
somebody had to get credit for naming it
even though that's what we've been doing
forever my words for it I used to call this
clean seems clean seems that means you make
a while I crash course so much cuz they did
this very thing
Ukraine ports and adapters it's like
adapters or interfaces and ports are ways of
communicating apis and stuff like that
yeah
I don't know
yet another name for good software
design that that most were doing anyway
without it having a name
since tonight is good but lately I got
popularize again
sounds about right the more things change
the more they stay the same
okay I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
stop ranting and laughing I'm going to
actually read it
yeah
if I can have a yes that's pretty that's
pretty Epic no ports no ports are interface
adapters Implement them
ports are interface adapters
horse our interface adapters in front of
them got you four to the interface adapters
in her application
it's basically a let's feel the rest are
architecture into it it's actually probably
a really great way for go to do because go
Cobra teens course he's a messages God you
can do for sit after is so easily I bet
that's why they made you do it somebody said
that they're going to do go development
there you go right there
we go goes goes concurrency is so strong
that you can build an entire you can build
an entire internal architecture within a
single binary that if you were to draw it
out would look just like microservices it
would look like a under support this
listening and then there's like a piece of
code within the code that's implementing how
it gets called and gets answered and stuff
that's microservices so it sounds like
forcing the dancers is micro services for
internal API integration that would be my
initial impression tray thing war on it but
that's my initial impression and that's
pretty standard that's pretty standard way
to do it you don't that way you're not
breaking it with like yeah I mean you could
do direct interface calls but even then
communication over internal
nut socket some message using stuff
a listing of application all right let's go
back to the origin
Mexican organization was invented by
Alistair cockburn an attempt to avoid no
instruction pitfalls in our generous offer.
Okay let's start their class based on
Victoria software design
go for the asteroids to see all the silly
nice he actually play it
we're going to make this by the way do you
know where the secret is for this
do you know where the secret is for this
makes me wonder if they did the secret from
head 4C head first he has a Blastoise game
built-in and we're going to write one
oh shit
flashlight keyboard
I know I'm easily distracted also majeski is
going crazy
I suck I suck a fuc
p p p p p p 2 2 2 2 2
is that space saucers Promenade
I saw kind of that that was fun diversion
back to your hexagonal architecture
is it going to get outside right now thank
you
yeah I might go cheap and use that instead
of go make my own casino game
if I have a card for that I gave her that
could I get a why isn't asteroid scopy
Rosanna made in 1980 it was actually later
it was earlier than that
CDL for C
composition of the related section
why is a master awaits there we go
back to hexagonal architecture it was a bill
to get around
is the bill to get around the pitfalls of
class based on aquarium programming such as
under the dependencies between layers and
can't and contamination of user interface
code with business logic happens all the
time
computer space evening strain how's it going
to yours
a in 2005 alright I have I have to actually
leave here in in 10 20 minutes to turn
hexagon all comes from graphic images that
show the application component like a
hexagonal cell
Jamaica custom the graphical conventions
that shows the application for like X
console
evermos is not just suggested that would be
6 mortar to Portsmouth to leave and space to
represent different interface is going to be
unemployment doesn't make any fucking sense
I'm calling Imports interfaces
it's not poison your faces for exports and
what
forts in something else Sports this is
hexagon is fucking stupid it's memorable
Orson adapters
how to make full stack app 2000 nostalgic
skeuomorphic Eli
1962 principal
is it illegal for a hexagon architecture
with an internet sound representing the
application core and they are hexagons for
the adapters that border between the two are
the forts God
the hexagonal architecture devised a system
into several Discovery interchange with
components such as the application for the
database user interface test strips that
sounds like him for you it sounds like
before MVP was the same test strips and
interface with their systems did resident
I'll turn it into the traditional layered
architecture a Campanile is connected to the
other store number of exposed Sports this is
just basic composition that's all it is it's
just this architectural composition at the
application layer is component look at
series philosophy make things that do one
thing well and then make them integrate and
talk to other things well first and adapters
maybe if it's the right a little of the same
weight lifting pretty pretty unusual
Assembly Language was still supposed to wash
his direct memory access that's what I've
heard
I've heard that people were using the same
way to learn assembly
the roaches nocturnal that yours on your
communication with these parts of the
following protocol does ping on a purpose
Fortune protocols and if I don't answer I
keep having to be any civil technical names
met him occasionally Korean language remote
procedure counseling services this isn't
this is nothing grpc that's probably what
they want you to learn grpc is I have a
feeling I bet you that's what they're asking
you about
I'm trying to see if they if they're asking
you about something else
aluminum cart service with DDD and exagonal
port adapter architecture part 1
Walmart global technology medium a
validation
accident architecture
application is Central to your system
Olympus in a Reacher leave the core of the
applications report Nice List application
for National statistics. He's yeah it's
microservices Chris is just microservices at
the at the late application layer level
tell me I'm wrong
he did without you ever see my point is
Jeffrey seems like one of them actually and
tell me I'm wrong
it's it's microservices internally its
internal microservices
and that's that's how my brain looks at it
hexagon was an actual name that got on ya
no not not know I fucking hate names that
don't make any sense or sit after is make
sense to me my new my new thing to call this
is internal microservices ways to make your
applicator internal architecture be right
here by an area should use microservices as
well and what is a microservice go
microservice go read it
it's something it's like I just have to be a
rest API intern a recipe I bet you should
have some in no point it sounds like it's
having an internal API for communication and
separates our internal core and Core
Business large aquarium to call it from all
of the external pieces and maybe calling
into an even if there is no static we
compiled in the same binary
thing is really great about that is if you
decide to break out a piece of that and
making its own independent piece you just
turn into microservice and you're good to go
cuz microservices is the same person patent
person has a pattern if I'm wrong someone
say something but that's what it looks like
so
sounds good I don't know ha ha by the system
into several loose a couple interchangeable
components such a case of core it database
user interface yeah. Just talking to each
other
each component is connecting with others to
remember we're supposed to Ports
Communications resource allowed to give a
call the thing on the purpose of exposing
things through ports with Ingo is a no
fucking brainer because go messages
I have yet to communication with his forces
and protocols to find an abstract if you can
give me a funniest any suitable technical
methods Services services
are PC web services method indication same
thing
I am reading a book for words that drives
our business logic which uses driven ports
like a TV Twitches of the ocean in yourself
from brittle connections between things by
creating interfaces
interfaces in ports of protocols that are
going to call him
I want to say in your face I don't mean in a
defining an interface of a certain number of
methods that when they say interface they
actually it is associate with methane
vacation but in that case I mean like how
you would plug the thing in in and that's
that's a pork like something listening or
Channel something like that and going to
call channel is single port could in some
cases be sufficient
also I think it's event-driven kind of
things go with his two right people are
there reports for Advance or that well that
was the next thing
it's the next thing they said your business
legit orchestrate Sossaman
typical airports for event sources user
interfaces automatic feeding of occasions I
think it's event-driven design is a way to
go anyway and then you have the vents go to
the ports and then you have your business
logic ft off the forts to do its thing
do anyone that truly decouple architectures
looks a lot harder to cut it that way but I
really like that nothing
I feel like I feel like that model works at
scale very well because you can even you can
even take that out of the application and
have the individual events be represented as
files or whatever and then you can have him
once a year for the Disney sports that's a
Gateway ya-ya component with any suitable
dbms
a demonstration of drinking but it could be
a different word for every use case
so far it hasn't said that the port has to
be listing on TCP IP the port is an
abstraction that could be internally
implemented as a channel and go for example
which is basically like and it's not but
it's basically like an internal web server
serving up you know restful apis to the rest
of the stuff inside of your application
and then everything is their application
could go get it never talked with a fork
that could be a bottleneck though
this kind of stuff probably that's why he
would want to use a different method like
method invocation
well that they're saying ports but I don't
think that they mean this one that's in
quotes I don't think they mean to be happy
for her
I don't think they mean that
I don't know I would be nice to know they're
using that word though it didn't they might
be ports and protocols
yeah for his use the interface is after that
I ended up for you
it could either be an interface that would
be high performance Melillo but it doesn't
have to be that way you could be an actual
Port it could be in go it could be an actual
an actual internal channel that listens to a
message and return the message
using shared memory which is how how
channels are implemented in go
so it could do more in a more strict sort of
thing or like you said forever for me to get
actually just be the implementation of
interface
Port means any way of importing or exporting
data API endpoints website messages
and I always have trouble with that because
when I think of what I don't generally think
of interface calls but an interface is a
form of a port
pipes that we absolutely
no problem as well to a pipes are harder to
do in in Unix yeah but they're basically
pipes yeah internal pipes
design patterns yes even talking about this
I got your ports in the numbers that
constrain the civil court for you could be
some
and what time was that sun serial
adapters adapters for the glue being between
couldn't stay outside world
what are the exchange between the external
one on the porch that represent the promise
of his side for a call
they can be sold a 41 Ford we have all three
can be provided by user through gooey and
I'm going to do this or is it just this is
just good application design I was already
doing it so you want to make you want to
make a really solid library that Scott is
built upon interfaces otherwise known as
pipes with adapters at pipes and then your
adapter would be the sea live version the
talks the library and you can have another
web version the talks to library in the
library remains independent
I'm a God
type of work clean architecture no
I the texicano architecture is what they
call it
pipes it was imported adapters
it goes channels must be fastened TPO over
the wire they absolutely are
they definitely are there internal that I'm
almost positive they're in front of the
shared memory
that's why they're so fast but the
abstraction of a channel helps you get your
head around talking to a thing that feels
like a port and it feels like a pipe report
or anything you send stuff to it you said
you actually send streaks to it and then you
get stuff back he gets trucks back from it
just kind of like a it's not but it's kind
of like an internal little H-E-B server
answering your stuff but it it distractions
helps
all things are pipes to write in a section
for the implementation of an interface which
is which is also the same thing right
a different use cases dcap do absolutely
areas
or the Martin Fowler my favorite Enterprise
business planners make sure you read it
I am back I need to go find Martin valves
explanation of this cuz the guy is fucking
amazing or is one of my you know what I need
to make a list
I do I have it I have probably 10 people
that are on my heroes listed like every
fucking thing I've ever said I just want to
do everything is said and Martin Fowler is
one of them weren't Fowler has spent his
life dedicated to start setting Enterprise
business patterns and irrespective of is
that a thing of of the without
a particular slant on what language or how
is implemented
yeah Enterprise business matters is like
mandatory reading that saved my ass at Nike
I have to tell you I had no knowledge about
Enterprise business better cuz I was like a
just a regular guy did you find
a regular guy did you find anything shit
do I have to search downloaded I hope I do
oh my God. Suck Jackie IP you already did
I know how do I have this book anymore so
I'm downloading it
I bought I bought this book and I just can't
find it now I swear to God I bought it like
years ago
did Eleanor send PDF Frank Lacey it Dairy
said it to you
j7 it's their Curious out scented it's got
the bubble of that couples a couple chat
messages is gots in its there
this book this is book is mandatory I think
it's more important to read this book than
most of the college text about about other
things because you know why it's this book
has been is the result of being
you know tested in the fires of Enterprises
like these are models that will sustain
things you want to do at scale whether
they're inside a single application you know
it's like it's like patterns people say they
teach about algorithms and data structures
that's fine I just feel it's really bad
because they leave the Practical Enterprise
business patterns or design patterns out to
practical is that did not that's not Theory
what the fuck but these are the ways that
you're going to organize your application so
it works and a practical level and they're
even talked about it don't even talks about
her and I am so glad I was just wandering
around the Tree House book store and I
actually saw it and I picked it up and read
it was one of the best books I've ever read
I actually need to re-read it we should
probably go through it on the stream it's so
good I imagine a lot of it stands the test
of time
I don't know that but
you're down move last
there he said I just did the power bash my
friends the power of Vash
I just ran a program that detected by date
which was the most recently down on the file
and move it to the current directory
from one command yeah
I'm bragging but every time I do something
about this super awesome I want to tell you
about it because this is why you need to
learn Mash
5 minutes ago I know I'm a goddamn it's 5:30
I'm supposed to leave I supposed to leave a
supposed to go like relax and sleep and
stuff
Valor is one of my God's I will not lie I
will not lie
patterns of Enterprise architecture patterns
of Enterprise application architecture move
patterns of Enterprise architecture to
patterns of Enterprise application
I may or may not have this on a PDF
it's good isn't it did you guys read it too
it's not just me
yeah I'm fine if I try to excite I want to
go I have such a hard time with you like
nonfiction because this stuff just like
really makes me happy
yeah it looks very 1990s doesn't it doesn't
look like the 90s
it looks like all the other books about Opie
that came out around the same time except
for I have a feeling I don't know but I have
a feeling that this one stands the test of
time
the other ones LP ones are shit now yeah
yeah it does cuz I'm kind of old
and I love you too I do too I used to all
the Three Amigos books everything hard
Valens I had them all I do I don't know gone
now
I don't know where they are awesome in the
divorce or something I have no idea where
they are
I mean this is this is all booked this what
came out like forever ago
MartinMartin's so funny listen to to he's so
Corky Corky. He's just
getting on the interstate in this vein layer
I think it might I think this is the first
time I learned the term domain modeling it
was either a reading this or running about
Ruby or specific and Ruby on Rails
Ruby on Rails is Raeford to make model and
crating Advanced specific language DSL acid
attack on the Three Amigos books
oh God no I remember this book to but no
no I think about the Three Amigos books
service or an architecture I'm not a fan of
that that's actually that's a 2010 2009
thing I remember when I was in Second Life
everybody was talking about Service radar
detector
if you wanted me to Services read the one
from Beezus
read this when it what was it
when business forever first visit was first
like to find what it means to be you know
microservices and then everybody jumped on
the bandwagon I think service-oriented
architecture came out of that
that is in a lot of people always yeah it is
2004 this is right around the same time
at service rain architecture is a solution
web service architecture what's a web
service yeah I probably didn't listen to no
I'm not printing it god dammit download
save what is this called
service-oriented architecture
patterns service-oriented architecture
oriented I promise I had coffee
so I don't want to take a nap it's probably
bad idea I should have done that was unwise
we could just say it already
are you guys okay cancel got that one
I'm in New Franken event move last boom
PDF service-oriented architecture we need
our, though
I should probably read this one again
basic web services this actually probably a
good book this is probably a good book to
read if you want to get into architecture
but that whole ported after a conversation I
think goes along with this really well
so this can we just please not talk about
soap
it's not the same thing don't get into the
old God there it is
please tell me it's not there soap I knew
was coming
we agreed never to speak of soap again we
agreed never to talk to Patterson can
I want to say this again
people have been around the block a lot and
when we hear somebody like Rave about this
new pattern this new thing is everybody
should do like OK Google where's my coffee
tell me all about tell me all about this
newfangled amazing thing is going to
revolutionize the world that we should all
use cuz I've heard this story a few times
do you think Frank how about Corbett let's
talk about Corbin in and then let's talk
about
talk about our PC
and those talk about coffee scripts and you
know class based on your eczema RPC exactly
I knew it was coming to somebody else has
had this this PTSD for me to people have
been around the block a lot when they hear
particularly young people and not just young
people but we need to get all excited about
this new approach or whatever the fuck like
hexagonal architecture which isn't new after
all I just got somebody's dragging out the
trash didn't we you know you know we start
to heal or we just remember all these like
you know going to save the world kind of
things when I heard about kubernetes I was
like this is going to be another soap
I'm not completely 100% convinced it's not
going to be
there I said it I love kubernetes I'm
learning it as my job I'm going to do
everything it does amazing things but
there's a lot of things that kubernetes
didn't do right from the outset
that I I have to ask myself
I've seen things that we're going to never
going to save the world in a transition
everything and they have just fucking died
nobody even talks about him anymore so every
time you see a somebody really excited about
a new thing going to ask yourself is this
one of these time-tested things is going to
be around for all eternity like an
capsulation that's going to be is detectable
better the future right
God knows it could be that he's is already
technical that right so is it going to be in
waiting to be I've heard people could relate
as the Mainframe technical that in the
future and other things like that and not to
mention fact that locks you into an upgrade
pattern forever right behind that already
with operating systems so
I don't know I don't know this I'm not I'm
not at my kiddo I'm like 80% converted is
going to be fine it's going to get better
it's going to be the new normal and you
could have said that about something as
simple as PostScript anybody remember
PostScript when's the last time anybody
wrote PostScript
like typed it out
I need a new know if you remember this but
when printers first came out it was a normal
thing to send instructions mathematical
instructions to the printer to create a
document
or that you just said ones and zeros and
you're very the grayscale on it and that's
raster right and then this idea of sending
Vector instructions to a computer was a
fucking groundbreaking thing and it came out
and everybody was if people were actually
writing PostScript and then nobody came out
and they they turn poster print to PDF PDF
begin the standard there was a time when
that was not accepted as the standard but
everybody openly accepted we just using
right now yeah and it was so so when is so
my question is is kubernetes PostScript
or is it coffeescript anybody even know what
coffeescript is
people do you remember it 5 years ago if you
weren't Cody and coffeescript you were an
idiot and everybody would yell at you what
do you know about coffeescript oh my God
you're at and then it became typescript in
Alexander so so
is it is made up. For testing receipt
printing yeah and people still use full
script to send instructions and they righted
graphql I grant you all I have is an
interesting one
refusal is a really really interesting one
what's your sense of it I feel like gravity
for me personally after seeing the Swagger
assisted API for kubernetes
I can't believe I'm going to say this I was
a huge graphql Fanboy and I'm starting to
I'm starting to be okay with plain Jane rest
apis more than graphql API is as long as
they have helper tools like Swagger so I
gotta tell you I am not nearly the graph you
a fanboy that I once was
yeah open API and Swagger I think they built
on the rest is pretty fucking solid let's
just be real rest is very solid it might not
be efficient but it's very very sore and I
feel like it's going to be around for a very
very long time it's not even
very long time it's not even really a thing
it's just a basic idea
there are 10 to 20 your cycles and check
where the same idea service absolutely and
there's a whole centralized decentralised
pendulum that's always doing that to write
during first date with common lisp wow
that's fantastic look at you go Frank you
really are a 10x programmer Raspberry Pi
a recipe by just waiting for apis to send
sequel databases around I think that's the
thing to you know what Chrome all of your
cash State and chrome is a sequel I did a
base
yeah it is
I'm ready for a big project move to open API
with cogeneration you did
well you just you just dropped graphql are
the expert Philip oh my God you just made my
heart flutter
that's exactly that is exactly what I'm
talking about I think Ralph he will solve
the immediate problem but was owed at yeah
we were talking about later earlier actually
yeah I didn't grant you all solve an
immediate problem that
didn't see the whole Forest right it was
yeah I think it was an interim thing first
of all it's not really practical unless you
have a highly complicated API with multiple
queries
you can that you can avoid needing graphql
if you design your rest API properly
you know what I mean yes does it save you
from extra calls the rest API yeah but if
the only reason you're doing it is to
improve the performance of your queries grpc
and put a buffer right around the corner and
acting can make like nothing can make like
forty fifty request in the space of one
draft he will Multi query request so if you
like it if you're picking crap 204
performance you're probably doing it for the
wrong reasons
hey yeah I don't know what that one but
it's Evangeline services areas close at 1 so
here's acid
and dedicated or have data could have used
your data absolutely believe I agree with
you so I actually was really excited about
the Rock Hill and it came out I really was I
got really pissed because it was released
under a close Source license by Facebook for
years
they eventually change that but you know and
that caused me to kind of calls on it but
after I've been doing so much with a
kubernetes apis and infrastructure from it I
can't imagine that something in front of a
gradual it would add so much fucking
complexity to the API API already too
complicated if you tried to complicate API
queries by making it into a query language
on top of all of that so you're not just
having basic states of different events in
in in a simple procedure calls I think you
would just fuck the shit out of out of out
of complexity of their applications I can
you imagine for example if the eight or nine
hundred API data points of the community's
API were implemented is graphql
no just know it would be a disaster if it's
a different thing right it's not it's it's
not nearly the same thing as designed to get
multiple data points in one pass and I know
that seems like what you want to do but but
the more I get into looking at actual like
huge apis that use open API in Swagger I I
like I'm kind of anti-gravity well these
days I'm not against it I just
you know
so I meant that this speed and size Aquarius
is there a current connection now and that's
that's all that can easily be covered over
by front ends applications like like to do
with the JH to land and most of them are
going to be making his father telling me
that the Cuban Eddie's API communities
itself uses internal grpc in front of us to
communicate for everything that though the
rest API is just the external eyes version
of it to talk to it but if but if you want
to you can talk to him directly through GRC
and if you're doing that you can make fun of
queries and it immediately and you don't
give a shit about about multiple queries
don't need to make all your get all your
data in a single complex where you can make
a bunch of individual ones
little ones and so that keeps their overall
architecture simpler because your queries
are simpler and you're dealing with with
individual data structures and objects and
stuff so I am there
patterns of Enterprise application
architecture is here gold acid
session State the value of statelessness
ways to store session state
large distribution object remote look on
your faces take as the language here
what are we doing we're just talking about
Enterprise business patterns so he was
asking about exagonal architecture otherwise
known as port and adapter architecture and
neck LED down the rabbit hole Enterprise
business patterns and conversations about
how to architect software in general
otherwise a bunch of boring Tech nerdy
Enterprise stuff
the patterns the main logic pattern the
meanwhile how it works when you use it
an object model of the Domaine that
incorporates the book behavior and data
it Revenue recognition I'd be interested to
see I mean this was definitely written back
in the object-oriented programming days
it was definitely written back then I'm
actually going to be leaving here pretty
soon fly my timelines for joining the time
I've been here since 11
I'll come back later tonight and do some
coding I feel like this book has been
I I don't know I feel like it's been
tainted by the classpass auditorium
programming of the day like this demesne
model conversation says the object behavior
and data that sounds a lot like a class
but it doesn't necessarily have to be it's
just figuring out what are the things in
your world and what do they do it doesn't
mean you're riding a class people took it to
mean that later but it doesn't necessarily
mean that data source architectural patterns
active record oh my God
an object that raps a row in a database
table review encapsulate the database access
and ask the main Logic on that data
wow this is old stuff
job as opt out job apps class beso P I'm a
big fan of Jim Copeland saying that job it
is not an auditory programming language
I completely agree I am so happy I heard his
rent I totally agree I can't believe you had
the courage to say it super amazing to me
maintains a list of adjectives affected by
the business transaction coordinator running
out of changes this is the kind of stuff
that I'm good at I'm not a good at breaking
down algorithms in numerical looping and
things like that I like to think that I'm
pretty good at Enterprise architecture
seeing how all the pieces fit together and
with the most efficient way to facilitate
communication and connect all the dots
that's that's something I feel like I mean I
feel like it's a big part of any it
professionals skillset to know what their
strengths are and I feel like I'm stronger
at that than I am doing the stuff that Frank
was giving me shit about yesterday you know
doing that like the low level stuff where I
have to like actually break down the the
computer science he kind of algorithm that's
in there I'm not good with that.
We can't back or interesting I can't back to
school to yeah he he he he debates a lot of
people
Fisher-Price crazy as well and we are you
talking about Jim
yeah I don't think he actually commented on
one of my videos because that's pretty damn
good coping pression I want to meet him in
person he's passionate I love it he's like
screaming at people I love it
it's funny
give me this you know I don't know that's
why the reason I have an open Curious elk
I'm trying to decide how much of it is
Tainted by Java
so for example this here I'll be relational
zahira pattern this this seemsthis seems
tainted by job a little bit
methods of identity map Java
this book came out the the patterns in it
are valid but so much of the book is Tainted
by the job at Eric came out in everything
back then was tainted by Java everything
lazy loading C how many people getting lazy
loading in Java
C sharp what the fuck this was to be a newer
version of it there was no C sharp back then
they're only written in these languages cuz
those are the only Enterprise languages
around back then that would be a fun
exercise we should probably do that yeah
that would be a fun lab yeah to Reemployment
the patterns and go
what's worse now
I know this is going to stand that this was
C sharp had barely come out back then
object relations function patterns
sister Davis ID in an object to intended any
between an MMO subscriber pattern I think
that's the one I can't remember the name of
it
oh okay oh God yeah classpass Opie's the
devil
it is I hate it
not even game developers use it anymore
these data-centric objects and then they do
other stuff
what is that you can actually do old people
job now or we go
pattern translation
I do do do that patterns translation that's
interesting
I can't find somebody to Matthew pattern
I'm presentations pattern isn't jaspy
I fear this book may be dated
I think functional is as a diet at all the
Doctor Jekyll I think it's still very
powerful
is ejsp as a Handler presentations on jsb
yeah that's that's a little hard to stomach
that one but I think I think simple is good
but again I am not a software engineer I
write a lot of software I read a lot of code
but I have no software engineers and you
know I am sort of Enterprise architect I
have done that in the past
Chester and how it works simple transform
God damn sv.net service Pages this is a
template View
rendering information into a shield by
embedding markers and an HTML template the
1990s this is pre-ap HP even I think how to
make a template View
original I'm try to keep I try to keep my
Performance Machine learning as close to
running and happy and invent new stuff we
have to deploy
this is crazy go has this go go templates
the basis of himself with by the way are
Kick-Ass they are amazing they are so far
the best I have ever seen and it has the
best direct code 210 phone extension of ever
ever come see it cuz he was so amazing and
you know how to function can be turned into
a template command
I thought Hugo was made just four of you how
it works when you use it you wouldn't exist
if it hadn't been for goat a goat able to
really deserve all the credit
application controller that's kind of
outdated
the situation better oversee data transfer
object offline currency patterns
yes okay we did a lot of this
becauseIf I Stay
yes business transactions how to plan them
how to do them off offline I didn't I use
the time I did get a job though
session State patterns kinds of these Powers
Gateway
mapper separator face registry I wouldn't
pay for this book I'm going to say it it's
it's so old I just download the PDF
just tell her the PDF and see if you can
learn something from it it does have
interesting approaches to
the world I've seen I thought it had the
subscriber pattern in it
did I miss that part baby I'm taking another
book
Bucknell don't pay that okay that
I could have swore subscriber pattern was
covered in here
there's your mom every controller come out
of a controller
I haven't already
I've started think I might be remember the
wrong book
is it the gate it might be the gang of four
design patterns you might it might be that
one
I'm at cuz I had that one too I think I
might be remembering the wrong one which is
bad I have to go find the right one I'm sure
that's available for free too
one of these books taught me to subscriber
pattern and not save my fucking life I was
like
I don't even know if it's called subscribe I
think it's it's supposed to call pubsub I
mean you see pups of Twitches using Pub sub
right now that's sexy weather made API
implementation
who else uses the OBS plugins up to
so
I don't know what's up my memory is shot I'm
sorry everybody I'm probably remembering
this this doesn't look from their seriously
maybe maybe it's got a different name in
here or something
command model
Observer power yes is there a pattern yes
yes yes thank you for that. That's what I'm
looking for the hours of the reporter is it
in here
session state I'm have to search it
there we go oh it is getting for okay so you
got it right yeah thank you Olivia guys
corrected my my shity memory it wasn't for
all this time I thought I was Martin Fowler
cuz that my memory is horrible and you guys
help me set myself straight I thought that
would give him credit for that all this time
all this time I was giving them credit for
the Observer phone
god dammit I feel I feel like my whole
universe is just collapsed
my reality is been changed once again by
realizing I remember something completely
wrong late he wants to can
God
I don't want to compress PDF that's a sure
way to get a virus you don't need to fucking
compressor PDF
seriously don't download ever a compress PDF
and run a compressor to uncompress it that's
like that's like trolling 101 fishing 101
I'm sure that's it I'm sure there's a man
out there download the original PDF it says
oh that one came down fine now that one just
told you the compressed one do the other one
and PS I was wondering cuz I don't know how
to directly hackable they are it's been a
long time since I looked at him there was a
time when you can save PDF to hack into
someones butt she just by using it
are you at least have it tell you that that
they were running or something
m move God
gang of four design patterns
that's fine you have gang of four oh my God
I am so blinded
blinded by that how much better
God
oh this is it yep yes this is it yeah this
is the one
yeah the interstates Reddit yes this is
definitely a visitor pattern yeah
yeah this is the one
you don't have to do this this uml by the
way I always I drink all of the Kool-Aid I
drank every last drop of the Kool-Aid I
obsessed about uml diagrams when I was a
Nike I had him all over the walls and put
them all out I was obsessed over your mail
you males become the bane of everybody's
existence are they still hackable can dammit
mr. Jim how are you
is about a representation of a I still think
looking at this is is worth it I just don't
think you need to implement in his
inheritance
any look at all this inheritance in here
this is a bad idea anytime you see
inheritance think of it as an implementation
of the visitor interface instead you can
replace this whole thing the creators of
gang of four one of the gang of four I can't
remember which one was asked what their
biggest regret was and it in a conference is
sun and rats with their biggest regret was
with regard to Java and they said
with red thread I was at guy yeah I was
composition is greater than her and she is
absolutely and he went he was asked what is
the single biggest regret he said
inheritance
and we talked about Java here right and what
he meant yet classic classes are in here as
one of the two and what he meant was this
this is I want to Jungle I got the I got I
want a banana I got the jungle problem
Platinum l i I know of plant you know I have
not use it now is it I have not use it
I use diaphragm iuml diagrams for our for
our DSL deployment
yeah. You guys are about Daya it's the old
tool we we maintain this like really crazy
ass diet diagram because it could render and
we would use it to render our software the
problem was any time we had any change to
the specification of the schema and then if
we change SQL I had to change the diagram
and rear end. Otherwise the to get out of
sink it so at best that kind of thing is
only good for creating your initial one and
ever since then I've never touched your meal
for visualization I've started to learn to
write sql4 the DSL and then use use
something that diagrams your data model
association's relations for you from the
actual Source instead of from the diagram
Bowser Eckley nice that's cool
Raffi's I did not know rational Rose God yes
it was us who use it used to hate it cuz
it's so much money
yeah rastros would render all your job I
could free automatic information and if you
would you had to re render your code every
time from the diagram
it's a visual programming a general is a bad
idea you don't know the reason you haven't
failed is because it turned into visual
programming
it turned into visual programming and people
like don't you can't rather than change the
code you need to change uml diagram and
remember the code and everybody was like
what the fuc
and then that died I died a horrible death
and everybody hates and now
he needs to know you'll know it's one of
those things that if you mention to people
that mail screaming you like the screaming
about Pearl like oh my God please never
again let's never use again
this is just so broken this inheritance
right here is so broken you should implement
this as an interface to seven Hernandez
but the overall idea is still sound. You
just don't implement it is inheritance you
can still answer but it is an interface so
it might be worth going through some of
these patterns in and seeing how they
translate into the modern-day that would be
fun that's more than academic thing but
what's a rational
yeah I remember that I remember that time I
was I was at what time in 98 I happen
it's all right I love you and I'll diagrams
but I use event-based diagram still I use I
use class time around all the time but when
I discuss timer G I just use I'm just using
the squares and I'm using it for the main
modeling and that's it
and you really can't even call you about
that point right you really can't
you your mail like simplifying class
diagrams without all the extra compartments
which is just a single rectangle is a great
way to do really quick and dirty domain
modeling before you start building shit
start making structured thanks I get here
just trying to if you're just trying to the
bleed out all of your ideas actually use
this
yeah I use this
I said I can find it
I did this for
so my curriculum
I had a over here it is delivery driving
instruction
yeah I did this again a model my stuff a gun
this is actually using this is not it this
is this is using pseudocode
as as that's not what I was looking for I
have another one
I can find it right now I'll find yourself
I think it's called delivery driven
education
yeah there it is
this is kind of my use of uml
this is what I was trying to put my trying
to do the Domaine I was trying to do the
main language for many things like
cardinality and stuff like that I still find
very useful
Box of Lies location I like cardinality I
like rolls I like stuff like that
I like the aggregation lines cell
this is this is my way I I went through a
crazy kind of moment where I was like
I didn't want to spend any time educating
anybody in anything that didn't produce a
deliverable
and so I am I obsessed for about a week
about what were the things in Ed skill stack
and ultimately the reason I did this is
because people were asking me physically
parents what am I going to get
and I would say you're going to get a bunch
of deliverables that you can use to prove
that you can do things to your employer's in
at schools
and so I really obsessed based on this idea
of delivery driven education in other words
I get something I can show that's not a
certificate
and if you do getand if you do get a
certificate is over here right
it was it was more of a waterfall thing know
I'll take it
yeah well yeah evidently was an agile no
because that's not completely Fair
that's I can see why they would think that
because you and Mel was you and Mel was a
thing that was used to to to analyze and to
capture the design of a thing in more of its
entirety before you got to work on it and
that is traditional waterfall right
waterfall is we don't do a damn thing until
we finish the design and then maybe we tweak
the design later if something doesn't work
that's why I bought her fall fails versus
Addie and Adeline in many ways is filled for
other reasons but but Angel meant let's make
a thing and then the sitter 8 let's make
another thing and let's iterate and that's
fine but both of them benefit from being
able to know what is in your environment to
do domain modeling
you know what the fuck you're building
there's a certain amount of analysis and has
to happen in agile or anything you could you
have to know what the fuck you're building
you don't know what to name things you don't
spend at least a minimal amount that's not
waterfall waterfall is in over obsession
with that step it's like we're going to
figure all the things out first and we going
to pay for Prototype everything and we're
going to have it all figured out and then
we're going to start coding I'm going to
send it to whoever we go visit Cody and that
never works and it never will work
it's still part of Angeles Just Dance
reservation at something and so that's what
I'm trying to say is to say that you will
always with waterfall thing I think is is is
inaccurate you know it's just a method of
capturing the Domaine model. Is it and
a front or during the process of the way
right I think the reason you became less
agile is because of what I talked about
people would get so hung up and and and
graphic because it was a model and could be
programmed and could be associated with code
a lot of Engineers immediately made it into
a form of rational Rose made it into a form
of graphic coding so people would write all
of their domain model out and then click a
button and it would generate all the Java
code for the scaffolding for everything that
had to be built
and you know it but that was very not agile
because you'd have to go back and change the
model and it might be fine for the first
shot but then and then people would be
annoyed because there were they were changed
the underlying code in their model would
match any more of being accurate and the
whole approach is fucked up the whole
approach is fucked up you and Mel at best
should have been a way to end it later later
solutions would grab a model out of the
database and then they would show you the
code what it represented and then you would
model that against what you had
is awful it's good for planning
documentation that's what I use it for this
is so things to things and I still use from
your mail I still use a composition
aggregation I use cardinality which is like
how many of the thing I use
I don't put the fucking I'm supposed to put
a colon in front of this because he's are
all individual implementations of a Class A
Classy style around if you're going to use
one of the thing you have to put a colon in
front of it stupid I don't do it
but then you have
the other things you have to know what the
things are so that so that you don't end up
doing some people just jump right in and
they start riding structures and I recently
I did that reason I did that when I was
writing my life to all right for modes I
went into it and I read them I get hers and
sweaters and I just sometimes I think you
can skip this you can do your domain
modeling by by creating destruction weather
is that love go whether it is a really
really love go is I can Define the structure
of my of my system and do them all in a
single-file initially and then I can say
okay here's the things in my system and I
can kind of see it all in code that's very
readable is still very yeah I don't need to
see the graphics but depending on how
complex your system as you need to start
having a diagram and I've I've done this a
lot I am a very visual guy so I'll drop the
phone a lot
you know
the curriculum is made up of several courses
and courses are made up of several lessons
and lessons are made up of several tutorials
while what's a tutorial a Tori of tutorial
for Tuesday's of deliverable if you follow
it it implements a project so there's a
project has been outlined and it is you know
an iteration is this specific invitation of
somebody doing a project step by step a
lesson lesson has repeatable exercises in it
these are different than projects so I'm
exercising for this section give me to go
through this because projects like we did
with you know the mnemonic many projects are
different exercises exercises are designed
to be repeated really easily projects are
longer drawn-out sort of things to test our
skills I kind of need both to master a skill
the scale needs to have an exercise to get
to know the repetition active recall going
on but then you need to produce a project in
order to get a deliverable something that
this is a
raise project or whatever so that then you
can end up with a delivery on this is what
gets you the job because you have a thing
and if you want to create a test you want to
test somebody's ability to do a thing you
can have them you can write review questions
related to the scale this is knowledge by
the way so I think they struggled with with
which it was tracking education in general
is the type of education there's there's
there's there's knowledge which is you know
terms and figures and history there's skills
which are I can type 20 words per minute in
a measurable there there repeatable usually
the primary thing they're looking for and
then there's abilities and it's k a s as
they're called they abilities are I can
leave people and stuff and they they're not
skills because sometimes abilities are in 8
and can't be learned sometimes they are I
can lift 300 lb for example that's an
ability is not a skill
but you need to understand what abilities
are even if you can't be taught about them
and being able to assess your SKS at any
moment is core to knowing whether you can do
a job or assessing someone else knowing they
can do the job so so when we focus on
education that's based on getting people
work opportunities we have to develop as
case we have to build a measure that have to
build a building and and and that's that's
where this comes from this what this is all
about and this is back when I was really
obsessed with delivery this is years ago God
when was this guy has it been 2,000 2015-16
and it just shows a relationships right so
this means is composed of hers and aggregate
of composition vs. aggregation composition
means that it can't exist any one of the
pieces can exist without the whole
aggregation means that all the pieces are
brought together and if any one piece has
deleted the other pieces continue to exist
so microservices rogation in a composition
adapters if they're all put in the same
program strictly speaking with would be more
of a composition situation cuz the whole
binary would delete it
those are those are basic architectural
principles that apply whether to software or
something and that that's one of the
arguments for learning computer science data
structures and algorithms because of things
like opposition those things can relate to
other things in your life so I'm writing a
book right as okay as soon as a bunch of
individual little ideas and thoughts and I
can combine those together in different ways
I can compose a aggregate them and I can use
them to build a different delivery while I
can build a book I can build a pan
flexibility toriel and I can reuse stuff
from all of them and that's that's very
strictly speaking a software design
principle that's being applied to writing so
I really think that some of these software
design patterns should be there by everybody
because because they're just good design
patterns. They're not they're not
necessarily just for software but I think
that software because of its complexity has
the paradigms in and you know that
patterns that have come out of software
solve all kinds of problems that we weren't
even planning on including organizing
knowledge exchange over the web
over the web you know composition subscriber
pattern when it's in a bit a lot of these
powders from software design can be applied
to society and in other ways and I think
it's really about the people learn for that
reason so
I would even go so far as to say that the
calculus in the learning to think like a
computer and all that stuff it actually does
mean
that you're learning learning to think like
a hacker so that you saw their own problems
learn how to learn and learn the story think
like a software designer
help you to just be a better human being
because you may end up solving problems
scientist depends on the size to go into you
but you're going to end up applying those
principles to other areas and you know it's
as Steve Jobs I'm reticent to quote him but
as Steve Jobs says it teaches you to think
that teaches you organize more importantly
organize your thoughts and that's why I
thought I was doing it I guess not I feel
bad that if our kind of went down I need to
read the book you now I'm kind of obsessed
because I I I remember it being much more
than what we just read and I could just be
remembering it wrong
so
alright so I'm going to call it a day
no you're the right one yeah that one I'm
going to eat
I'm cute you think I'm cute you're cute
you're cute too
you like my shirt for some reason my wife
likes my shirt nods
you like it cuz it's cut nice makes me look
good
I'm getting I'm getting you order me long
johns and a hat
Okay I accept woman
and they had a gray wolf Adora or not
$7 for a great War fedora
okay my wife it did you buy yourself
something nice
to buy really cute boots
I kind of have a lot of boots Long John's
long johns okay on Johns and socks I got
Auto long-johns did you know this thing
purse
imagined it did
it's not big enough though I know it's like
it's it's not a certainly not cozy but it's
cozy enough on your neck I know it's exactly
right here it's right here in the night I
talked to him if you can listen to it
what temperature is a very soft I know
feels like a heartbeat
every time every time I I get yelling I do
this and it makes me calm down
this is what I do just comes me down
oh you're getting those crazy eyebrows I'm
not getting crazy eyebrows
I don't have enough eyebrows if I've had
enough eyebrows out
look like a little lotion or hairspray so
that they fan out cuz now they're just
cutting out and then I could be what's his
name that crazy guy with the with the
let's let's no no no no no let's keep the
crazy guy in the vice thing who did the
government money for free guy let's go let's
go
supposed to bethen they sell that if I just
shave him off
it's kind of grown out okay alright do you
have any thoughts on my nose hair
swimming shave off of I know I know
is Massachusetts that there's an entire
twitch category about about how to maintain
your like face and stuff I know what it was
I put my my my things up my I put my things
up in that made that that's
yeah and then she shot my pants is she I
know you wear something this really sucks
okay all right
on the Supersoft on you are cuddling
cuddling is better than sexy I can go they
go together sometimes they have a picture of
her with her red long johns on on the bed
remember that one
I do with your trap door that's supposed to
be mine and you wore my long johns and then
did you give me Tractor long johns or they
just like two piece long johns
regular bear bottoms okay are they Patagonia
or no or just change my category to Fashion
I should change my camera action
no I think I'm just going to turn it off and
get yourself a partner who knows how to do
comfy hell yeah especially when you get old
him
see now it now we're definitely in the old
dude fashion comfy socks
keeps ice comfy
it's like oh my God is it logistically I
need to take that for
I know they are you're the best for getting
them for me
socks sock him it's the sock him
countries where it's at yes nice socks they
like my socks
premium content old guys socks
hair so, they have their lined with like
this fleece so that I just hugging your feet
it's so nice and they're not too tight
yeah when socks get to tighten up on your
cap and I dig into your calf you know
I don't see how people ever were okay with
that or guy shows that sucks at 11
you chose
oh hey good morning for feet related content
just saying they you know I've heard that
I've heard that's true people like they like
feet
it's time for the any fans only fans I do I
can't even get the name right it's that it's
time for the onlyfans the art of the ex Rob
only
socks with socks and fat guy yoga
they're saying some people pay good money
for feet related content I'm just saying
so we should have an only fans for like our
socks me and you with our socks
oh I don't know if that's what they meant
what the hell is this it is
I yes yeah oh my God yes
yes I agree I should go for those eyebrows
oh my God
Queen I can't I can't do the beard you know
I should
don't dye your beard what's going on today
kind of Pookie
I like your beard right now yam
what
hey Google pull up pull up pull up for me
she keeps you to take care of my video she
puts like on the big TV right here it was
like fun things on the window on that's on
the television
I asked not as Marbut like snow storm it's
actually snowing
I can open it wait
behold the snow I can't see it God damn it
you know what I watch movies that made us
last night and they cover Halloween and
Friday the 13th one after the other and I
could Square
I was going to die that night I was so
freaked out I was so freaked out by
there's actually snow out there but you
can't see it yeah
what Halloween costume do it want us to
dress like this for Halloween
I can do that that we could do a kick-ass
cosplay for that
course you could do it oh my god did you
know there's a whole section at Michaels for
cosplay now
we were just walking to Michael the other
day
what's our what's my topic I think I'm
probably just Hammer I am hanging
wait they want to see it
as a nice one the very nice one
yeah that's a nice one like that one so
that's that's my work TV
drinking amaretto
but yes it's actually really nice it looks a
lot better than you can see it but it's like
it's very very very cozy
I heard for costume design for shows I agree
my son is big into costume design as well
they have it as a career you know
it do they have it they have that the whole
thing as a career
anyway wait what happened to MOSI
ramazi masi masi masi
you know this is you know that she is
Michael's really
you have a tripod kind of
does the Smite old are L rig if you go back
into the other videos
cuz of the enemy approaches it made what
what enemy forces that make
what are eating now
we're going to eat pretty soon when I cancel
the stream just letting you know so you
don't get surprised who else is streaming is
probably some good people on right now I'll
come watch them said to me
oh my God it's open the window is like so
cold now I guess it's time for food
it's time for food
crooked picture frames yes I have crooked
picture frames I definitely do
I do it's got Fine Art in there to that
piece is like five hundred bucks or
something I need to straighten it
later for Witcher I think you might be right
and then I'll be coming back from which or I
can never promise what I'm going to come
back I really
so very great a great day today I feel bad
that we didn't capture a lot of stuff
permanently because of the filter they got
to fix that we have some fantastic
conversations with different people
and that's all that's all I'm sick of that
Wim Hof method for programming just open the
window
I don't know what that means I know that
means you're speaking in riddles
tell me what did you see my CC I got work I
told you already about that right look at
this look at these live captains that
actually right right here
look how easy this was to set up and it
shows me exactly what my capsules are going
to be down here before it sends them this is
my life closed captioning and then you go
you go to the site and you just click on CC
and it does the CC just like you do
I thought you would appreciate that we're
going to go eat dinner
we talked about their not popping up for yet
they should be there God dammit
are the first to CC button on Twitch
is it not working now you got me worried
which are they from CC
until about that wynhoff later I don't know
what that is
how come I see Caesar and popping up either
God damn it did I fuck it up
what did I do to my see some popping up
either or there they are they're on now
okay good yeah they were off
they're on now okay good yeah they were off
basically involves very cold water and
health benefits from it I've heard of this
I heard of this I don't know I don't know if
I'm man enough to do it though the whole
cold water thing
they said that they just have ice cold water
at the fountain of youth was the name of the
spa my dad used to go to
yes I'm getting ready go visit me if
clicking on stop by everybody
call me back for wicherski for notifications
on if you want by